from exclusive items to portion sizes we
want to find out all the differences
between kfc in india and the us this
is food wars
[Music]
here in india we have two types of
chicken sandwiches a crisper and a
zinger in the u.s we have two chicken
sandwich options the chicken little
because it's little and of course the
kentucky fried chicken chicken sandwich
the classic now let's weigh them to see
how much they weigh
obviously
this thing has not been cleaned
in a very long time all right first up
the chicken crisper
our chicken little in the us weighs
next up the chicken zingo
240 grams for the classic chicken
sandwich
this thing is a work of art all right on
to chicken popcorn here in india we have
it in three sizes regular medium and
large
we're gonna weigh our large popcorn to
see how much we get
i actually really love
chicken popcorn
i have an idea we should weigh one
popcorn chicken and add that back to the
total my bad my bad they should serve
this in movie theaters
i don't want regular popcorn anymore
i love that they sprinkle in a bunch of
sesame seeds and it adds a nice crunch
to it
what sesame seeds we don't have that all
right you guys are lucky that sounds
really nice we only have one size that
going to the website and the kfc i went
to and that is this
how accurate these measurements need to
be really
oh it's so good
unfortunately here in india we do not
have mashed potatoes but that would be
pretty awesome we do have fries we're
big fans of them and they come in two
sizes medium and
large
and in the us we also have two sizes of
fries at kfc the individual for an
individual and the large also for an
individual let us now measure the large
to see how much you get
140 grams
[Laughter]
that's never not funny that's the third
time that's happened and it's always
funny look at that block of fries our
largest fry
is more than double their largest fry
here's our individual
150
our smallest is bigger than their
largest
in kfc india we can get our chicken in
six portion sizes
number one
the
single piece
two piece
they like to give you one breast piece
and one leg piece
kind four piece leg piece to top it all
off the leg piece on top as they say
like cherry on top no okay now we move
on to buckets we have four sizes the
first one is a five piece bucket that
comes with only leg pieces and also does
not come in a bucket for some reason why
kfc i want a bucket
next up we have a six piece bucket an
eight piece bucket and the largest one
of them all a ten piece leg bucket
that's a lot of chicken in the u.s our
kfc chicken comes in seven portion sizes
one which you can get a la carte
two-piece with a combo
three-piece with a combo
four-piece with a combo then buckets
that work okay we have an eight piece
guide pieces
the 12th piece
[Music]
and our largest bucket the 16 piece
ready julie
you get the idea
next up you're gonna need a drink to
wash all that chicken down here in india
we don't serve cups we just serve cans
we have pepsi seven up mirinda which is
an orange soda red bull and a pepsi pet
bottle however these will vary from
store to store in some places they might
not serve plastic and in some places you
might not get these drinks you might get
something else they also serve something
called a virgin mojito crusher which
they don't deliver unfortunately but
here's an image of it
refreshing
american drinks come in these following
sizes the regular which is 20 ounces and
the large which is 30 ounces and hey you
don't have there if you want you can
also get half a gallon bag of your
favorite drink of choice look at this
thing
it's convenient
here is everything you'll find on the
menu at kfc india that you won't get in
the u.s here's everything you can find
at a kfc in the u.s you won't find in
india take a look india take a good look
okay let's start with chicken in india
apart from the crispy chicken we also
get smoky red chicken
wow
i believe this is kfc's answer to
tandoori chicken if you guys don't know
what a tandoor is it's basically a
cylindrical oven that they light up
using wood fire or charcoal and it adds
a really smoky flavor to the meats or
breads that you cook inside of it i
doubt kfc's across the country have an
actual tandoor but
flavoring definitely smells like that
the marinade looks like that
oh my god
that's actually pretty good
you know what kfc
pretty good job
you have to remember kfc is competing
with a lot of mughlai restaurants across
every indian city and while this doesn't
have as much of that smoky char that a
lot of tandoori kebabs have
it has a lot of flavor and the chicken
is quite juicy
good job
it's super spicy though so if you're
somebody who can't handle spice
go a little easier on this one when an
indian says something spicy it's spicy i
believe you man i believe you that looks
incredible we unfortunately don't really
have anything too spicy on the menu for
the like chicken and the bone options
really the only thing that we have here
that apparently you guys don't have is
something that is like what i associate
kentucky fried chicken with is extra
crispy i don't know exactly what makes
it extra crispy but it is as you can
imagine crispier than the regular
chicken
extra crispy to me is far superior to
the regular way liquid chicken i think
it should be the other way around like
this should be the regular and the other
one should be like
half crispy you know what i mean this is
all this is way better all right let's
move on to chicken sandwiches here in
india we don't have an american chicken
sandwich but we have a zinger and a
smaller sandwich called a crisper cute
the crisper looks like it wants to grow
up and be a zinger someday they also
come in two variants a spicy crisper and
a tandoori zinger let's taste all of
them
oh it's pretty yum they've used a
different kind of mayonnaise here it has
a bit of sweetness to it and a spicy
kick at the end
and now for the legendary zinger um back
in the day there were only two fast food
chains here in india it was mcdonald's
and kfc and while mcdonald's had more
affordable burger options the kfc zinger
was so delicious it was always a treat
to eat
and it still is i love that they use a
whole
boneless piece of proper chicken in
there
delicious mayo it's so delicious okay
now let's try the spicy variance this is
the spicy
crisper look at this sauce
it's almost blood red i'm excited
oh my god
the sauce almost has a schezwan taste to
it next up the zinger but tandoori
i love the fullness of the chicken that
comes in these burgers versus you know
like a minced chicken patty in other
restaurants there's so much bite to it
so juicy tender that all sounds amazing
steph you're going too fast i have to
say those sandwiches look delicious and
i am jealous one sandwich you can get
here in the u.s can't get in india is
this little guy
the chicken little looks to be
like a chicken tender
in between
these tiny little buns pickles goodbye
[Music]
i could really get like five of those
slightly different from what you have in
in india so i'm gonna use it as an
excuse to show it off yet again our
crispy chicken sandwich this thing the
original the bad boy
also with pickles hang on
get off of my sandwich but it has this
really creamy mayo sauce on it the bun i
love this
yeah
other chicken stuff
we got here you ain't got i'm already
getting loopy start over here nashville
hot tender chicken here this i think is
the spiciest thing you're getting at the
kfc menu and it'll be straight up like
i've had these before these are pretty
good they're really crispy julie you
want to hear that crisp again
not sure if it's made it over to india
yet it is called a chicken pot pie
that's a pie but instead of there being
you know fruit or any of the sweet stuff
you like
they fill a pie with chicken and what do
you think else is in your corn gravy
peas maybe i have no idea i'm not gonna
rip this thing open this thing
has got some weight to it this is a meal
right here this is not a side i don't
know where it is on the menu but
this right here the kfc
famous bowl and it is famous let me tell
you
nikhil if you're wondering what this is
someone at kfc was like how can we put
everything into one bowl and this thing
was born it is
mashed potatoes corn uh the popcorn
chicken
cheese and gravy
on a convenient bowl for you to eat
while you're driving
it generally does nothing for the flavor
is exactly what i would think this would
taste like
it's just a bunch of this stuff in one
bowl
yes in india you can get wings of the
kfc but our kfc in the u.s you can get
your wings sauced and we have three
different sauces honey barbecue buffalo
nashville hot
honey barbecue thumbs down this
buffalo's a lot more orange than i
recall buffalo bearing i cannot quite
place my finger on why suddenly my
stomach is killing it
do you see inside there
okay
on to the next one
bring on that food poisoning baby
um
yeah all these are bad
all right moving away from chicken
india's kfc actually has vegetarian
alternatives for all our burgers there
is a vegetarian
crisper a vegetarian spicy crisper and a
vegetarian zinger now while india has a
majority population of non-vegetarians
around 70
there is a huge vegetarian population
which is why a lot of fast food
restaurants have to make sure they have
a lot of vegetarian options on their
menu to make it more approachable and
acceptable for all people over here
there's also levels to vegetarianism
over here there are i will eat egg but
not chicken vegetarians there are i will
eat fish but not lamb vegetarians there
are i will eat the curry but not the
peas is vegetarians there are i am
vegetarian only on tuesdays vegetarians
there are i have made a promise to god
for this one month vegetarians there are
i am vegetarian so you will all be
vegetarian vegetarians they're the weird
ones and we try not to talk about them
which is why kfc in india brands itself
as just kfc there's no kentucky fried
chicken anywhere here because obviously
i'm not going to go to a place that's
named that if i'm one of these many
types of vegetarians one iconic dish
that you'll find on the kfc india menu
is
biryani and so kfc india has taken a
very bold decision to launch their own
biryanis if you don't know what biryani
is you are living under a gigantic
boulder my friend hey guess i live under
boulder because i unfortunately am not
familiar with biryani but i would love
to know more about it
hello i am christelle pereira and i am a
cook and a baker and you may know me as
a fine artist from the great british
bake off this is biryani now biryani is
a typical rice dish you find in south
asia and the way you make it is in
layers my dad is a biryani master at
home and the way he makes it is with
cooked rice cooked potatoes some fried
onions and a curry we like to go for a
mutton biryani but you can get chicken
or fish and in this case vegetarian
biryani we absolutely love it and we
always eat it as a family unit with a
lovely pot of cooling writer on the side
which is a lovely cooling yogurt dish
which goes really well the spicy biryani
and it's basically our equivalent of a
sunday roast because you have it in a
big pot and you all take scoops and i
actually don't think i've ever eaten
biryani by myself for one person now
we have to talk about this kfc biryani
because for me biryani it's a home dish
you make it in a home kitchen it's
cooked by a family member and it's
cooked with love my first impression at
kfc biryani those two words just just
don't go together for me just to give
you guys context of what it's like to be
indian and eat a biryani at kfc it's
like being italian and eating a pasta at
domino's
got it thank you
continue they come in four flavors
number one classic chicken nice and
crispy number two popcorn chicken
number three the spicy red chicken that
i really enjoyed and number four the veg
patty which
it's so tempting to just push that to
the side because veg biryani
is already just a concept that we not a
fan of over here
but just for
just for now you can you can stay here
okay i'm gonna begin with the popcorn
chicken biryani which is just so
blasphemous to begin with
it's not a biryani
it's
i'm so upset right no
this one the spicy red chicken
has a bit of that tandoori vibe to it
they really try to over compensate with
the spices there's a lot of clove flavor
just to convince you you're eating a
biryani so
go easy on that curry
i could eat this like if i was hungry
not a biryani though that biryani looks
real depressing i am sorry but we do
have these exclusive side dishes which
are mashed potatoes i can't believe you
guys don't have mashed potatoes it feels
like this is like flagship stuff here
macaroni and cheese biscuits again no
biscuits
coleslaw
this
giant dish
of just gravy and of course sweet corn
new country new sauces y'all know what
that means
sauce talk
first one i mean the kfc sauce why this
isn't at every kfc internationally i
have no idea gonna load that sauce right
there
and it's like ketchup and mayo
that's really good uh honey barbecue
i know that tastes like
honey mustard
that's not your thing
honey
and of course you got classic ranch
not much of a ranch aficionado
but those are just okay
and oh i forgot about the hot sauce
julie
6 40 p.m
india does not have too many exclusive
dips in fact we just have a veg eggless
mayonnaise and a tandoori masala
mayonnaise it's time to taste
i'm using the same hand because here in
india we don't eat with our left hand
if you're wondering why commenters you
let them know
why don't indians
ate with their left hand
[Music]
well it's just mayonnaise so
good job on that
mayonnaise again with a little bit of a
sweet but also spicy kick to it i wish
we had more options especially
considering there are so many
different delicious chicken options i'd
love to be able to dip my tenders in
more sauces that is a weird sentence for
those of you with a sweet tooth we have
two exclusive dessert options chocolate
chip cookie
and this
chocolate chip
cake
what does this look
here in india we have two exclusive
desserts a choco mud pie and a coffee
mousse cake
ooh
boy
just look at this cross section my
friend
next up
coffee moose cake
yeah um
these are
pretty average as desserts
drinks drinks drinks
maybe my favorite part of the exclusive
section exclusive drinks again in the
u.s you cannot get in india mountain dew
i'm back baby
and if you're mountain dew fan such as
me
you know kfc has got the exclusive
mountain dew sweet lightning so mountain
dew sweet lightning is like peach
mountain dew it's really good it's
really good
i think this is a lemonade the u.s style
lemonade not like that weird uk sprite
lemonade
not so good from there you can also get
serum mist
and of
course sweet tea
whoa that's like really sweet oh that's
really good
exclusive drinks in kfc india we have
mirinda which is an orange soda and red
bull let's talk about miranda
this is a drink that really evokes
nostalgia 90s kids
really know what i'm talking about when
i say
mirinda
which country is getting the better deal
on its kfc let's compare a few menu
items to find out both countries offer
eight piece chicken bucket here in la
one of these goes for 19.99
if you order an eight-piece chicken
bucket here at kfc india it will cost
you
699.05 rupees
very specific which is currently 9.15 us
dollars that makes the american 8-piece
bucket 118 more expensive than the one
in india does making your meal a combo
help the us price out at all
take this chicken sandwich combo with
fries and a drink it will set you back
in america 9.99
the indian equivalent is a zinger meal
where you can get a chicken sandwich
some medium fries and a drink for
319.05 rupees or 4.18 us dollars in fact
the price difference is so great you can
get something called the ultimate
savings bucket for just 599 rupees or
7.88
and this contains
four pieces of hot and crispy chicken
six heart wings four boneless strips
three drinks and three dips
yeesh
in fact you can throw in a choco mud
pie's dessert and still get all of this
for much cheaper than the american combo
meal but is it really that cheap here in
india no because two thirds of india are
still under the poverty line and for
them this meal is still very
aspirational they earn less than two
dollars a day sorry to be a downer but
this is still a meal that is only
available to the really privileged here
in india
unfortunately kfc does not share a full
list of ingredients with the public it's
actually the same in the us all kfc
shares with the public is a list of
allergens so what do we know about kfc
well the kfc india website has a couple
of clues we know that all of our chicken
is farmed here and not imported and all
of it is 100 whole mussel chicken
that means it's made from whole pieces
of chicken and not cut together minced
chicken like you find in chicken nuggets
in fact the website says they have an
open kitchen policy and what that means
is anybody can walk into a kfc and
apparently ask for a kitchen tour and
you can go into the kitchen look at
everything and ask as many questions as
you want
i've never heard that in my entire life
an open kitchen pot i've worked in
several kitchens and i'll tell you
straight up i was in a kitchen working
and some dude walks in is like hey gotta
tour the kitchen i'd be like yeah here's
your tour there's the exits definitely
can't do that in the united states don't
go into kfc chicken and demand a tour
the kfc us website also gives us some
hints about the ingredients it uses over
here for instance all of our chicken is
raised on u.s farms to the usda and
fda's standards so that means there are
no added hormones or steroids in
american kfc chicken in addition to this
as of 2019 yum brands the parent company
of kfc stopped purchasing chicken raised
using antibiotics indian chicken farmers
were previously criticized for overusing
antibiotics as recently as 2018 the
bureau of investigative journalism found
out that a lot of indian farmers were
feeding coal steen to their chickens as
a growth promoter without any medical
supervision kolestine is known as the
antibiotic of the last resort holy
oh my god
they're so frightening and it's only
given to humans when other antibiotics
have failed so if we give our chickens
coalestin then the humans who consume it
might become resistant to it in fact
they can develop a antibiotic resistance
superbug and that's not good julie this
sounds like the plot to a horror movie
what is he talking about
that is terrifying
i'm gonna assume we don't do that here
and if we do
oh god
but when a report came out talking about
the ill effects of coalition india ended
up banning it completely so we're safe
from coaliston at last
we should also point out that the kfc
india website is in major need of an
update there is an faq page where people
have asked things like how many calories
does this chicken have or
sometimes i see red deposits in my
chicken
what is it
and for almost all of these questions
the answers are just filler text so if
you ask me what those red deposits are
i genuinely don't know that's
interesting let's take a look at this
website right now
is kfc providing healthcare to the
employees kfc responds standard dummy
techs ever since the 1500s when an
unknown printer took a gallery of type
and scrambled it to make type specimen
book
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between starbucks and india and the us
this is food wars
at a starbucks in india we get our hot
coffees in four sizes number one
a short
a tour
a grande
and the big boy
a venti
i can't think of a single reason you
would order a coffee of this size who is
putting this much caffeine
in their body me nikhil mei
let's measure this to see if it has as
much as it should
whoa wait a second
starbucks
i'm disappointed it's close it's 18
ounces ish all right if i'm paying this
kind of money i want a bang for my buck
20 ounces to the t i think that's 20. i
was about to dunk on starbucks but
actually gave us the 20 they promised
cheers
look into the eyes
of an insane caffeine addict
my vision has just gone blurry india's
iced coffee comes in three sizes
tall
um
and an even bigger one we got the trenta
i want to mention now that our venti ice
size is bigger than our venti hot size
the venti hot was 20 ounces this is 24
ounces and of course
let's measure it
can't believe you've done this
it's not even 16 ounces starbucks and
this has ice in it which should melt and
give you more liquid is that is that how
fluid dynamics works maybe not
but my disappointment is is palpable
yeah i'm going to go 22 ounces ah it's
two ounces that's fine
totally not a big deal that's like two
sips i can't speak for anyone else but
already my bladder is about to burst so
maybe i don't need 24 more ounces in my
bloodstream if that wasn't exciting
enough
we of course have our biggest ice size
which is the trenta 30 fluid ounces the
bladder buster this is for anyone who
wants to spend most of their day in the
bathroom
so you think what 28 again two ounces
off you know starbucks four ounces more
won't kill you
ah it's actually pretty good
starbucks actually good what the hell
anyone who watches food horse knows we
use this measuring cup for everything
and i know i don't clean it
and i don't think joe's cleaning it i
don't think julie's cleaning it so this
thing never been clean yeah
and of course if you're in the mood for
96
fluid ounces of starbucks coffee ba-bam
get yourself the coffee traveler aka
what joe drinks in an afternoon here in
india we don't have a huge coffee
traveler we just have
this little guy it's an india edition
tiny pet coffee traveler it's got a lot
of cool india iconography on it there's
a batsman there is an elephant
all sorts of cool indian stuff and you
can put in 355 ml of coffee in here
which is around 11.83
ounces of coffee roughly a tall so
the perfect size we also have one litre
bottles for iced latte and cold brew
word on the street is they contain one
liter each or 33.8 fluid ounces it is so
weird using the u.s system of
measurement i'm so used to our normal
correct metric system but uh let's not
start an actual wall over here sorry joe
yeah
i don't care
let's take a look at calories a hot
venti latte in india is 289 calories for
comparison a normal serving of dal
chawal is 200 calories
in the u.s the same venti cafe latte is
250 calories so it looks like the u.s
has
13.5 percent less calories
it's at that temperature where it's like
room temperature
my brain my brain is swiss cheese i
don't know everything i say is idiotic a
hot venti mocha which is also what my
friends call me is 473 calories and the
us are venti mocha is 450 calories so
according to my math once again that's a
calorie decrease of 4.9 percent what do
you think of that hot venti boy
okay joe it's not a competition
let's just try something a little
sweeter like this venti caramel
frappuccino which looks uh
decadent to say the least
oh my god that is
so sweet
602 calories and i can feel every single
one of them in each sip okay genuinely i
have had spoonfuls of sugar that are
more savory than this drink
how can you make something sweeter than
sugar
how
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a lot of calories my man ours is
470 calories which is also 24 ounces now
i should note in the us the calories
listed on starbucks.com are quote based
on standard recipes and do not reflect
customizations
get this out of my face i hate this why
is this so and they put like they load
the syrup in here how can a human being
drink one of these i don't understand
and now our most calorific overall drink
that we have here in india a venti
strawberry and cream frappuccino
963 calories
oh my god i didn't even think it was
possible to experience a sugar rush
and a coffee caffeine high at the same
time at 963 calories this is nearly 50
of your daily caloric intake so please
drink this at your own risk and i am a
risk taker
i feel transported to
another dimension where everything is
more colorful and i can taste sound
i don't know i feel like we should have
an ambulance ready if i'm going to
finish this drink that's a lot of
calories i have to say i'm very
impressed our most highest calorific
drink is the mocha cookie crumble
frappuccino at the venti size and it's
only
590 calories oh god
this looks so bad
oh man it's it's like so powerful like
it's so sweet that everything from here
after the rest of my life is just gonna
taste like paper
so what about the cost this venti
frappuccino will cost you 390 rupees
which at the time of filming this video
is 5.14 us dollars
in the us a venti caramel frappuccino is
5.45
or about
413 indian rupees now i want to point
out that this is 24 ounces and not the
india 20 ounce venti so if we break it
down per fluid ounce it's about 11.5
cost per fluid ounce decrease in the us
let me give you some context about
starbucks in india they are catering to
the rich and the elite because it is
very expensive over here in south india
where i'm from you can get a filtered
coffee for less than 40 rupees which is
a fraction of a dollar and it's
delicious starbucks would cost you
upwards of five dollars and that's
unaffordable for most of india
here is everything that you can find in
a menu at an indian starbucks that you
won't get in the us quick clarification
some of the items we have here are
location specific and specific to the
season that we're ordering them it's
currently summer here in mumbai and some
of these items are store specific so
maybe you won't get them in hugo order
but let me know and here's everything
you can only find on the menu at a us
starbucks you can't get in india now a
bit of clarification we know starbucks
will customize drink orders and there
are thousands of variations in special
secret menu items hey thank you
starbucks so just to make things not
completely insane these are the official
things on the starbucks menu at both
india and the us cool and let's go all
right let's begin with all the hot
exclusive drinks starting with salted
caramel latte
not bad stardust
mocha
boom we have clarified no sparkles
nothing about this cream stardust i
don't know what you're talking about
starbucks but it tastes good
chai tea or as we call it here in india
chai can i just say it's a bit of a pet
peeve when you guys call chai chai tea
it's like calling t
t t let me describe a good chai to you
all right it should be warm it should be
gingery it should feel like a hug from
your mom in your childhood and it should
perk your morning up and it should be
under 10 rupees but this is expensive
[Music]
hello it's christelle and i'm here to
talk about chai which is actually my
favorite drink every person has their
own recipe for chai but it's a
combination of spices and black tea and
some milk and usually sweetened with a
bit of sugar but for me at home my
recipe cardamom is the most important
spice cinnamon ginger a pinch of cloves
and my secret spice is a bit of black
pepper just to give that lovely warming
spicy feeling but but it's not savoury
it's just a lovely blend of spices
the flavor is not bad but i wouldn't
call this i wouldn't call this a chai
you know what this is a chai tea because
it's not quite a chai it's not quite a
tea
fair enough starbucks it's a chai tea
next up in the drink i'm most excited to
have tandai spice now tanda is consumed
primarily in north india in the state of
uttar pradesh where it's this drink
that's sweet it contains spices it
contains rose petals saffron and
sometimes optionally you can add bang
which is marijuana and it's completely
free legal and optional to add it and
people enjoy it during the festivals
like holi and mahashivaratri well i'm
sorry did he say that that drink has
marijuana in it or you can put wheat in
it i mean this is california so if
there's a drink you could put weed in
you think we would have it right
not bad
it's got little pieces of pista and
badam and other nuts how did you get
tanda right and mess up something as
simple as a chai usa we got a lot of hot
exclusives i'm gonna start all the way
down here with something called the cafe
misto
bland moving on almond honey flat wipe
this flat white i like because it has
like a nice honey flavor to it but
straight up flat whites i just i don't
get it cinnamon dolce latte
i like it it's not too sweet a white hot
chocolate hot chocolate come on
this is like really good but i don't
know if i could drink a whole one of
those this is the caramel apple spice
oh next steamed apple juice what apple
juice hot apple juice what are you
getting like with some apple juice right
about now i haven't seen it forever
let's meet up for apple juice cinnamon
dolce cream
steamed milk
and barf vanilla cream when you walk
past that ice cream place on the mall it
tastes the way it smells like strong
vanilla i couldn't imagine have more
than two sips of that already my
stomach's starting to hurt i'm gonna be
so sick and now it's time for the cold
exclusives i'm not having a caffeine
crash at all
the citrus cold brew
citrusy out of everything this one has
kind of a nice mild flavor the cocoa
chai almond
i just had such a mild one i took a big
sip and this one is
sweet again vietnamese caramel cold brew
it should typically have condensed milk
but this has normal milk and it's quite
good nitro cold brew it's basically cold
brew but if you press a button you drink
it faster
dumb joke
it tastes like any other cold brew i'd
be interested to know what the nitrogen
process is what is what is nitro cold
brew well they add nitrogen to it and
you know what that does
i have no idea
next up chocolate ruffle cold brew you
know that sounds like something your
child self and your adult self would
want to combine if they had to
collaborate on a drink let's see if it's
actually good
[Music]
absolutely not oh my god stardust mocha
again
i still don't know what the hell
stardust is there are chunks of
something
something otherworldly
it's it's like cookies and cream it's an
oreo it's an oreo tanda spice
same flavor but now cold
too much sugar for one young man to
consume i'm losing it
i'm seeing the light
oh no i'm literally seeing the light
there's a light above me you know the
funny thing is tanda is meant to be
consumed cold so this is the appropriate
temperature and way to drink it but it's
layered with so much whipped cream and
it's so sweet tanai requires a balance
of spices and sweetness and that's what
this is lacking and the final two drinks
are salted caramel and strawberry with
cream but i already tasted those maybe
maybe it got better with time you never
know you got to give everything a chance
[Music]
i'm never giving anything a chance ever
again and now for the pre-bottled drinks
they've got three of them in one liter
bottles this is the ice shaken hibiscus
lemonade looks quite refreshing
that is very nice it says it serves four
to five cups which if you're in an
indian family they're going to make this
last for at least 20 people
and it's very reminiscent of rouhsa
which is a rose flavoring that we add to
water and it's super delicious i think
this is a good substitute white mocha
caramel cold brew
oh my god i've gotten to the stage where
i can smell sugar i can see sugar i can
hear sugar i think i am sugar at this
point
starbucks signature chocolate normally i
would be very excited about this but i
am so soaked to the brim with sweet
stuff
it's actually good it's like the amount
of chocolate you want to put in your
cocoa but you know it's probably not
good for you
i'm losing my goddamn mind
alright starting down here something you
can only get in the us is the mocha
cookie crumble a frappuccino it's
looking a little sad
so
food wars tip
bring your own whip
that's in all joe's tips
i'm not getting the cookie part of it it
just tastes like a chocolate milkshake i
don't know if that's really doing much
for the flavor the caramel ribbon crunch
frappuccino
i don't know how anyone could drink a
whole one of these the recommended
serving for this joe should be like two
sips it's like sip number two
and i'm good for a week oh that high
fructose corn syrup is working overtime
in that one the cafe vanilla frappuccino
you know always keep this thing on me
the least objectionable one i guess
actually a little weak to be honest then
again after these two maybe it's
perfectly fine nitro
the official cold brew of the fast and
furious franchise joseph just pour this
on your engine and off you go off you
and vin diesel go it doesn't require ice
has a smoother flavor right now if you
want something a little bit sweeter than
your cold brew you can get yourself a
vanilla sweet cream nitro cold brew okay
joe [ __ ] with it we got our vanilla oat
milk we got a brown sugar oat milk and
we got a chocolate almond milk here they
are
not as strong of a flavor as i thought
it would be brown sugar
i'm definitely tasting it yeah not bad i
have reason to believe this was
unshucking i think i could shake it
without
i would recommend this one out of all
three but insist they shake it in front
of you you can get yourself an ice flat
white and an iced honey flat whites
skip them iced cinnamon dolce latte and
an iced starbucks blonde latte
not bad
can confirm a sip is good i don't know
about a whole one of these already i'm
kind of like
starbuck teas or as my mom calls them i
can make this at home
starting off with indian spice majestic
wow okay
oh
can i just say drinking this after
everything else is such a breath of
fresh air you know it's a simple tea but
it's very flavorful very spicy
would recommend next up matcha espresso
fusion it's part of the trifecta of
three ingredients that have become very
popular in india matcha peri peri and
red velvet
[Music]
i feel like the espresso counters the
sweetness that it has and the matcha
flavors there again just cut down on the
sweetness and this would actually be
good now the exclusive hot teas you get
here in the u.s the royal english
breakfast tea latte london fog tea latte
honey citrus mint tea a jade citrus mint
brewed tea the mint majesty
mint matcha green all bad the trinity of
gross i don't want the peach tranquility
and they spot tranquility but it should
be tranquil like tea i feel like they
missed a trick there okay so those are
the two hotties it's now time for the
cold tea starting with an iced green tea
i feel like when you start drinking
green tea it's a sign of adulthood and
there's no going back
that's actually pretty good and now i
feel old
hibiscus passion lemonade so many
ingredients but i know i'm gonna taste
only sugar hey
that's pretty good
it's kind of flowery fruity i really
like this
espresso fusion oh this is an iced
matcha okay sorry
my bad my bad it's guys it's a starbucks
handwriting honestly sometimes i think
it's just doctors writing prescriptions
on these coffee mugs by the way let me
know in the comments what's the weirdest
way somebody has spelt your name in
starbucks
i prefer this to the weird hot sweet one
yeah i like the teas way more than the
coffee so
i don't know what that says about
starbucks but
i'm a fan i feel the exact opposite i do
not like tea at all and this is all the
stuff on a starbucks menu i've never
gotten and would like to never get but
gotta do it it's the job so we'll start
down here at the starbucks in the u.s
you can get yourself iced black tea and
an ice black tea lemonade moving on you
can get peach teas we got an iced peach
green tea and an iced peach tea lemonade
so this tastes good because it's like
peach and lemonade i don't taste any tea
green iced green tea lemonade
el grande not gr's the first giant's
granny grande ice cream tea lot latte
lemonade i'm losing it see i don't i i
stop drinking caffeine for a second and
i fall apart oh matcha no
no not much huh grinding matcha lemonade
all right lemonade lemonade is doing all
the heavy lifting on all these
i absolutely hate this royal english
breakfast
mmm
you know what help a little caffeine
all right also starbucks is something
called refreshers so what i can tell
they are fruit juices with fruit in it
imagine that i would never normally get
a refresher i just wouldn't think too
but not going to try all of them pink
drink
oh yeah fruity moving on we have the
strawberry acai lemonade
i like this similar problem to a lot of
the frappuccinos one taste and i'm like
i could get into it but a whole one of
these and i don't feel my gut kind of
starting to look just the mango dragon
fruit right dragon drink mango dragon
fruit lemonade
i think this is the best one so far
one second all right
don't put that in
moving on we have the green drink zone
star drink assuming star fruit kiwi star
fruit does lemonade kick it up even
another notch
hmm this one i like the flavor the best
was a little strong yeah all these are
pretty good the last refresher is the
strawberry acai they have a regular
lemonade and a blended strawberry
lemonade i mean come on lemonade
everything else has had lemonade in it
i've enjoyed so let's just go straight
to the source
whoa dude starbucks lemon is like really
good
is this even the top 10 things you would
get at starbucks a lemonade what now
it's like your lemonade a little bit of
strawberry
this is fantastic wow even after all
these this is a standout this is really
good why is this so good
fantastic
food
we have a lot of indian exclusives i'm
going to start with the salads this is a
vegetarian grain salad it's got quinoa
it's got some paneer in it it's got
corn kernels that look unborn
i'm sure this is super healthy but it's
also very dry now the meat version of it
it's got chicken
i'm not really a fan of cold salads if
you are a health freak you might enjoy
this but if you're a fan of food
you probably won't okay next up i'm
going to try all of their rolls rolls
are a huge staple here in india they're
one of the most famous street foods and
it's great for the working class citizen
this is the murg kathi roll murg means
chicken in hindi
oh that's pretty good
finally some spice
oh my god
this is a lifesaver i feel like i'm
being brought back to life after all
those drinks this is really good you'll
find this only in india but honestly
starbucks you should consider selling
this all over because it is tasty
next up is a kakuri kebab roll kebab is
basically minced
meat typically lamb and it's served with
a paratha or a roti i've never seen it
in a roll and i've never seen it in a
pink roll
um the main thing about a kakari kebab
is it should melt in your mouth this has
too much of a bite to it not a fan next
up chatpata paneer roll chatpata means
full of masala and flavor and it's zingy
and paneer is cottage cheese we love our
cottage cheese here in india and we call
it paneer and you should too
next up cheese chili toast so obviously
if you order this at starbucks i assume
they actually toast this and the cheese
melts and it's super delicious
i can tell you right now this flavor
profile will go really well with indians
we love our cheese chili toast monsoon
season mom goes to the kitchen toasts
the bread lot of butter some cheese some
chili bite into it your mouth's on fire
but it's rainy and cold so you're all
okay this is not quite there but i feel
like it could be next up tandoori paneer
sandwich i'm gonna have to say that this
bread is a little
hard
to say the least might be a bit of an
old sandwich
flavor is good though if i had any of
this food fresh at a starbucks i might
have a very different opinion so far the
paneer items have been way better than
the meat items i'm starting to guess
there's somebody in the starbucks r d
team who really likes paneer
sandwiches and protein boxes here we go
you can get a bunch of exclusive
sandwiches us starbucks starting right
here with the crispy grilled cheese and
sourdough again ham and cheese on a
baguette then we got the turkey pesto
with provolone and chipotle
chicken and bacon on brioche why is it
can we get that chicken on the whole
thing here guys a focaccia tomato
mozzarella at a starbucks you can get a
chicken caprese on chibata sandwich on
to the protein boxes
the chickpea bites and avocado can you
tell what's in there obviously avocado
chickpea bites egg and cheddar
cheese and fruit peanut butter and jam
grilled chicken and hummus there's your
hummus there's your pita there's your
grilled chicken you can also get which
was not available at the store today egg
and gouda protein box a cheese trio
protein box in a cheddar and salami
protein box next up egg white and
chicken multi grain quasar should i just
call it a croissant to upset people the
denizens of the internet
if you are somebody trying to be protein
conscious put on the pounds this might
be good for you next up a masala chicken
quasar
i guess you can't go wrong with masala
chicken you can't go wrong with the
croissant it's just really good next up
a basil tomato mozzarella sandwich
i can imagine just eating this on a
summer day really yum next up creamy
spinach and corn pocket pocket that's
pretty cute as a kid this is the only
way i enjoyed eating spinach unless it
was in palak paneer but right now i
appreciate it and i really like it in
this pocket next up chicken chic pocket
cheekbob is basically minced meat and
it's sort of pressed onto your skewer
and then grilled over here they've done
that and then they've chopped them into
little sausage pieces
minty it has that pudina flavor a lot of
onions that have just been caramelized
so it's like sweet but also spicy i
really like this starting with the
breakfast sandwiches and wraps the bacon
gouda egg scooter somewhere on here
sausage egg and cheddar the double
smoked bacon cheddar nick dude
hammer swiss croissant and bacon sausage
egg wrap what's up
i didn't
other sandwiches you can get are spinach
feta egg wrap the roasted ham the turkey
bacon cheddar and egg white sandwich and
the impossible breakfast sandwich but
you know they do have bacon and greener
egg white and roasted red pepper kale
and mushroom get yourself an avocado
spread for dipping
bagels we got em i'm gonna assume this
isn't everything cause it's got
everything cinnamon raisin i can tell
because of the raisins a plane for the
new yorker right oatmeal oatmeal we got
regular and they come with a nut medley
brown sugar dried fruit i bet it's like
a puck now it's been sitting for a while
all right
you can also get a blueberry one it's
obviously the same stuff with
blueberries
strawberry and overnight grains next up
a double chocolate chip cookie
i think if i put this in the microwave
for five seconds this is a bang and
banging cookie a tea cake
this is a lemon flavor and finally they
have a banana loaf cake but guys i am
dangerously allergic to banana and so i
wish this cake the best of luck maybe
you guys can try to let me know in the
comments whether it's worth ordering and
the baked goods in the u.s you can get
an assortment of baked goods as you can
see in front of me i'll just start down
here we got scones oh this is a
blueberry scone petite vanilla bean
scone these can't be the same price
cake pops yeah chocolate which one you
think is earth or which one you think is
birthday
like this is gabby birthday glazed donut
hey
red velvet cake pumpkin loaf you can
also get a cinnamon coffee cake yeah
brownie
chocolate chip cookie available yet not
today pumpkin cream cheese muffin it is
now time for ice creams did you know
starbucks makes ice creams i had no idea
java chip ice cream this looks really
good
check it out sun
yum
coffee chocolate chips and mocha that is
something else i really like this next
up vanilla ice cream and chocolate sauce
now everybody in india their childhood
has involved
amul vanilla ice cream and hershey's
chocolate syrup let's see if this sort
of evokes that nostalgia
oh the vanilla ice cream is so good next
up vanilla ice cream with strawberry
sauce you either got the hershey's
chocolate sauce or the hershey's
strawberry sauce
younger kinney would not have
appreciated this but olekini kinney
really enjoying it it's fruity tangy
sour and it really complements the yummy
vanilla creamy ice cream next up we have
the same java chip but now with
more choco chips and chocolate sauce so
this is a bit of an overload
too much are you can you zoom in on my
hand
it's shaking right now caramel macchiato
hmm
it's really nice it's not too sweet it's
kind of salty
next the affogato which is
ice cream in coffee
i love how we're taking hot bitter
coffee and sweet creamy ice cream mixing
them together and somehow they're not
choosing violence they're choosing to be
friends
harmonious in my mouth
i forgot to again but this is house
affogato so i'm gonna assume starbucks
that this should be better you're
putting your name on it
tastes the same and finally we have the
caramel macchiato ice cream it's similar
to the small cup of caramel macchiato i
had except this does not have
a drizzle of caramel sauce if you were
ordering ice cream from starbucks i
would recommend the simple java chip and
the simple caramel macchiato
no drizzle of sauces it's not as sweet
it's kind of nice
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between mcdonald's and india in the u.s
this is food wars
drinks in mcdonald's india come in three
sizes regular medium and large drinks to
the mcdonald's in the u.s four sizes
extra small small medium and large
time to keep them honest
lost a couple drops 26 27 fluid ounces
fries in india come in three sizes
regular medium and large in america our
fries come in four sizes i think
we have a
small kids
or
kids small i can't tell the difference
either
medium
and large the medium and large come in
these really cool new packaging where
you can just
open it up like that and it's nice and
easy to share it's a little plate good
job mcdonald's very innovative but now
it's time to measure and see how much
we're really getting first things first
the large
175 grams obviously it's different per
scoops or whatever yeah let's go ahead
this one almost exactly 100 grams
this one
80 grams fry math hang on
this is like
yep there you go 20 that's 20 gram
difference right there so you tell me
internet is the kids in the small
different sizes i don't think they are
food wars is on it right baby what about
mcnuggets here in india you can order
them in three sizes
six pieces
nine pieces and 20 pieces they gave it
to us in two boxes of ten each oh is
that it india cute our mcnuggets start
at four
then you got six
ten
twenty
and not to be outdone booyah 40
mcnuggets all the math heads watching
will be quick to point out that that is
double india's largest nugget option the
only burger that india shares with the
us is the mcchicken the humble mcchicken
not even going to bother with the analog
scale now
boop
149 grams ah
so frustrating just one more gram and
it'll be perfect
with the paper i mean
we'll do this
and shave off
an eighth of an ounce our mcchicken
weighs 140
grams
[Music]
here is everything you'll find on the
menu at mcdonald's india that you will
not find in the usa and here's all the
mcdonald's menu items from the u.s you
won't find in india here in india we
can't really recreate the iconic
mcdonald's big mac because it's made
from a beef patty and to keep to the
religious sentiments of hindus and even
muslims we don't serve beef or pork in a
lot of fast food restaurants we have
something called the chicken
maharaja mac as you can see it's got
three buns two patties a lot of cheese
and mayonnaise some tomatoes onions
lettuce let us try it now
[Music]
oh my god
there is truly a maharaja mac
if you're wondering a raja is a king and
a maharaja is like an emperor so this is
clearly our answer to the big mac now
let's say it's the veg maharaja mac i
think it's actually a very cool
challenge that a lot of fast food
restaurants here have had to adapt to
the indian palette as well as
sensibilities of food we have come up
with such cool
iconic fast food that you won't get
anywhere else in the world like look at
this this is outrageous there's no way
to eat this without being messy this
literally wrote away
mmm oh my god that's really good yes to
all that
looks really good because of india's
lack of beef all the american beef
options are technical exclusives
all right
big mac there it is
just
brimming with stuff
my go-to for like 20 years i still get
it occasionally the classic
mcdonald's hamburger beef patty ketchup
and mustard of course
and get it with cheese hi
you can upgrade to a double cheeseburger
or a mcdouble what's the difference you
ask
i'm not sure either so let's start with
the double cheeseburger look at it look
how yellow that is
beef cheese beef cheese tacos the
mcdouble is
beef
cheese
beef so it's just one slice of cheese in
the middle but not on top what's the
price difference can we get that on
screen
and how much is a slice of cheese
joe's hack get yourself a mcdouble and
bring your own slice of american cheese
booyah save yourself this amount of
money
problem with millennials today the
reason you guys can't buy houses is
you're spending all your money at
starbucks you're getting your double
cheeseburgers instead of a mcdouble and
bringing your own cheese slice i mean
you guys are terrible with money what
are you eating what seven eight
mcdoubles a day like me right that adds
up to like at the end of the year
18
10 000 years later that's a down payment
on a house
wait
what are you guys doing all right next
up is the iconic mikalu tikki burger you
take mashed potato and you fry it in
breadcrumbs and you get this really
delicious cutlet here in india they
adapted it into this
burger with a very special sauce some
tomato and chopped onions
it's just so classic they nailed this
burger next up there is a mexican mekalu
tikki which i assume has
stereotypical mexican ingredients and
flavors like jalapeno yes jalapeno
nice it's way more spicy good twist
next up they have a mech egg burger make
egg
make egg make egg i don't know why i did
that let's see what that looks like oh
sorry i did not expect pesto
next up is a chicken kebab burger every
time an indian fast food chain tries to
adapt an indian special
food into a burger i take it with a
pinch of salt because this is not what
we're used to seeing when we think of
kebabs but i'm gonna try it and let's
see what happens
it's very very dry
patty has almost like a cardboardy taste
to it i wouldn't put those flavors
together if i was thinking kebab
make cardboard tikki maybe no okay
that's a bit harsh i'm sorry next up is
the mech veggie which is the vegetarian
counterpart to our mcchicken
if i had to eat this versus the chicken
one i would not be upset at all
really good next up we have two american
burgers the american cheese supreme
wedge
and the american cheese supreme
chicken
my hunch for what makes them american is
that they will have a nice big square of
cheese and they will not be spicy at all
except they have a lot of
jalapenos on them joe let me know if
this constitutes
american that's american cheese my man
that's what makes it american i don't
know about those other toppings but yeah
that sounds about right all right so
this is what the mcdonald's website says
is in this burger whole wheat bun source
from maharashtra tangy jalapenos from
karnataka
shredded onions grown in local indian
farms
and cheese from amaravati
also
in india quite quite close to home this
burger currently this would probably be
my favorite order a mixed spicy chicken
and there's the vegetarian option which
is a mixed spicy paneer which is just
leaking lettuce for those of you who
don't know what paneer is it's basically
cottage cheese we love our paneer we put
in curries we eat it plain we put it in
kebabs
it is so delicious let's try this
has just the right kick and goes really
well with the paneer fair warning while
this may have a light kick of spice for
us it might be a hard kick for you so
take everything with a pinch of chili
powder i'm gonna move up to something
called the quarter pounder and that's
like their big burger so you can get a
quarter pound of cheese here it is i
mean this looks it looks fake right like
just kidding it's cake or the the new
one is uh it's actually a candle
and then you can get a quarterback with
cheese deluxe more veggies on it all the
junk that i brush off you can upgrade to
a double quarter partner with cheese
let's take a look oh man
look how thick this is
and then you can get that same double
with bacon yeah oh man skimping on the
bacon guys
what we lack in beef burgers we make up
for in gourmet burgers that's right here
in mcdonald's india we have our own
collection of chef special gourmet
burgers
delicious and i think this is a rolling
menu i think they introduce new things
from time to time the buns themselves
look a lot more
gourmet you know there's a nice riff
down the middle kind of looks like a
butt uh but that's okay we're not going
to concentrate on that
first up we have triple cheese american
veg burger and triple cheese american
chicken burger same thing cheese
jalapeno some sauce lettuce simple
chicken patty a gourmet bun does this
cream american to you next up cheese
lava american veg burger and cheese lava
american chicken burger again with
american and again with the with a
strange relation of food to volcanoes
and lava
okay
this burger is very spicy
this qualifies as a volcano product for
sure congratulations mcdonald's the lava
in the title of this burger works
the mex spicy chicken premium though
has an egg patty inside of it
that's pretty good
i just feel so existential right now
imagine sitting here at this table and
just tasting every single burger
mcdonald's
menu amazing
but also
we also have some exclusive wrap options
we have big spicy paneer and big spicy
chicken i think this is the same mex
spicy chicken patty and it's wrapped
around a tortilla which is actually way
closer to an indian chapati than most
other fast food restaurants it doesn't
feel as
synthetic our mcdonald's in the us had
wraps for a brief period of time one day
they were gone nobody noticed yeah you
guys got some chicken stuff that we
don't have but we got a few of our own
more recently than you think they
finally introduced their chicken
sandwich to an already crowded chicken
sandwich market and that is of course
their crispy chicken sandwich and this
thing is fantastic it's one of the best
ones they relate to the game and they
kind of took it over in my opinion i
like about it it's simple look at this
you just got crispy chicken pickles that
suck it's baller tastes great like a
little spicy india
it probably doesn't compare the way you
guys are rocking in india but you know
this one has a little nice heat to it
pickles sauce wanna take it up a notch
gotta go deluxe
the cool crispness of the vegetables
just clash so well
with the spicy sauce it's good it's good
nikhil say the word and i'm putting one
in the post for you tomorrow so when it
arrives in three weeks you can throw it
out
now we're getting into exclusive side
dishes here in india we have these
add-ons number one
the veg pizza mcpuff this is one of the
most delicious things we have here it's
basically a pizza hot pocket masala
veggies these are potato veggies with
classic indian masala flavor to them oh
boy masalas are basically what we use to
spice and flavor dishes and they consist
primarily of ground up spices like
cardamom cloves
red chillies kashmiri chilies you go to
every indian home the mums the grandmoms
will have their own random you know
masala mix that they use and that's
guarded and treasured in their family
forever next up we have cheesy masala
veggies they're also serving a classic
cup of boiled corn which is so unique
and they give you a side of amul butter
guys amul butter is part of our culture
makhan
makhan
this is probably gonna be the most
delicious bite of the day
i love corn
next up chicken strips they come in
packs of two
three or five cheesy
nugget veg bites yeah this is just a
vegetarian version of the chicken
nuggets and it's got some corn some
tomato
it's okay
next we have the double cheese mcmuffin
and lastly we have mexican cheesy fries
on the mcdonald's india website one
british customer said that these mexican
cheesy fries are the real deal
i have no idea how a british person can
say that mexican cheesy fries is the
real deal but anytime a british person
says that another culture is food is the
real deal it puts a little fear in our
small indian hearts yeah surprise will
look ass and the next exclusive side
that we have is apple slices
cut them up
put them in a plastic bag about to get
saucy that's right ladies and gentlemen
sauce talk
thank you
they got a tangy barbecue
oh
much better
honey mustard
tastes like salad dressing sour
i would tie it with the tangy barbecue
because it's so different so we'll keep
these guys
sent here
ranch i don't know america we love our
ranch that's just okay that's why i said
it ranch is just okay oh
and all ranch tastes the same
yeah
and finally honey
i like that
honey's the best one and all that money
all that energy all that time creating
all these recipes trying to sway the
american popul the american mind and you
got you got beat by a bunch of bees
power to the bees
we have one exclusive spice mix as well
as one exclusive sauce here in india we
have chili sauce which is pretty
straightforward it's chili sauce but let
me tell you about piri piri spice
mix so mcdonald's launched this in 2013
here in india
and it was so popular there were riots
when they said they were going to
discontinue it and so now
it's a permanent addition to the menu
first you get this shake bag then you
grab your fries and then you just pour
that in there
oh boy
can we cut to a before of the fries and
you saw how they were now look at these
you can see the little flecks of spice
just adorning each fry
[Music]
hello it's christelle and i know nikhil
has perry perry mcdonald's chips but in
the uk it is all about nando's cheeky
nandos let's talk about perry perry
perry means pepper and it's a blend of
spices so it's got things like paprika
ground bird's eye chili a bit of oregano
a pinch of ginger and cardamom but it's
a portuguese spice blend it's funny
because obviously nikhil mentioned that
the peri-peri fries just blew off in
india and it makes sense because i'm
from goa which is in the south of india
goa was colonised by the portuguese and
so i really think that indians are
accustomed to that portuguese taste
palette which is why peri-peri fries are
doing so well in india but after the
talking i want to dig into these fries
because they look great
that was just so good harry get involved
not eating chips without me no sorry
everybody had a head start
cheers
god damn if there isn't
like crack
for the early risers there's plenty of
exclusive breakfast items at the u.s
mcdonald's sausage biscuit with egg next
one
sausage biscuit i'm gonna take the egg
out so it's just
this of course is bacon egg and cheese
ladies and gentlemen we've reached the
point of the breakfast where we get into
the mcgriddles i love mcriddles what's a
mcriddle you ask india fantastic
question mcdonald's had this genius idea
to replace the breakfast sandwiches they
already had with pancakes
and they also like inject
syrup into it somehow but it is a
breakfast sandwich with pancakes or buns
and it's the best idea anyone's ever had
anywhere ever
look at this look at this look at this
this is like a little m in there this
mini pancake i know i'm running the
gloves but this was mine
we have a veg mcmuffin and a sausage
mcmuffin
the sausage here in india is not made
out of pork like it is in the u.s
instead it's made out of simple chicken
speaking of sausage
you can get breakfast burrito
bro i could put five of these away using
easy you're like a total drag
and you want oatmeal in the morning we
have it it's about as inspiring as you
would think
hot cakes and sausage of course it comes
with hot syrup this here
the big breakfast with hot cakes and
it's big a lot of eggs kind of wimpy
looking bacon
got yourself two english muffins here
and of course it comes with hash brown
potatoes who doesn't love them
mcdonald's hash brown
undefeated these things are so good
india exclusive desserts we have a black
forest mcflurry a vanilla chocolate
muffin and a chocolate chip muffin it's
kind of like
a mcflurry soup right now
this would be really good when it was
actually a mcflurry desserts usa we got
them so starting down here very simple
choc chip cookies
uh this next thing apple fritter right
this right here is called the glaze pull
up our donut
blueberry muffin if you had one you've
had them all this is a what type of pie
is creamy pie let's see what's inside
okay i'm suddenly more interested yeah
guava and cream
how about we'll call it the cream of
guava pie
now this sucks
standard menu item the mcdonald's apple
pie everyone knows about this i don't
want a pizza version of this
and last but not least cinnamon roll too
sticky i don't feel like eating it
update it's not sticky it's actually
exclusive drinks starting with we have
something called
b naturals mixed fruit juice
next up we have something that they call
raw mango fruit splash
oh
it's a bit too sweet berry lemonade
splash all of these come in these
very
unique reusable bottles apparently next
up strawberry chiller
green apple chiller and
lemon chiller
it's just flavored water that's exactly
what it is it's flavored water and i
kind of like it this is a mixed berry
smoothie
it's still quite sweet but quite good
next up american mud pie shake
that's pretty um drink roulette ooh and
the ice melted fantastic
dr pepper let's go
coke not exclusive
let's go sweet tea too sweet
oh yeah unsweetened tea not sweet enough
you guys combined for the kids watching
why are you watching where are your
parents or supervisors you can get
yourself apple juice
milk come on drinking milk the thought
of drinking straight milk like it hurts
my stomach there's also chocolate milk
on the menu once upon a time this was an
iced french vanilla latte now it's more
of a room temperature french vanilla
latte
it's just okay it's like really like
really sweet strawberry banana smoothie
yeah i always love getting these these
are good
so i'm gonna assume they're not good for
me exclusive hot drinks first off we
have strawberry green tea next up uh
english breakfast tea
and
moroccan tea next up a flat white coffee
india a land where
we run on chai and mcdonald's does not
have a chai option
caramel macchiato cappuccino
caramel latte a vanilla cappuccino the
fingerprint that v does look like a you
mcdonald's premium roast coffee
i'm gonna hang on to this one
in india a chicken maharajamak will cost
you 231 rupees for just the sandwich
that's around 3.03 us dollars we do not
have the chicken maharaja mac but we do
have the big mac and a big mac in the
u.s cost 4.89
that is a 61 percent price increase now
what if you turn this into a meal a
mexiwa maharajamak combo comes with
regular fries and a regular drink and
will cost you 356 rupees that is 4.67 us
dollars still less than the price of the
american sandwich on its own but does
the combo meal make a difference in the
us a medium big mac combo so big mac
medium fries medium drank it's
8.99 that's a 92
cost increase even worse than if you
just bought the sandwich on its own on
the indian mcdonald's menu you'll find a
two-person meal which contains a chicken
maraja mac a veg maharaja mac large
fries two pizza mcpuffs and
a drink all of this will cost you 681
rupees or 8.93 us dollars so basically
you're getting food for two people for
the price of one person's meal in the
u.s however while it seems a lot cheaper
than the food in the u.s it's still very
expensive and aspirational to people
over here your minimum wage per hour is
equal to our daily minimum wage and so
yeah a lot of people can't really afford
this kind of food the english-speaking
indians that you see in a lot of youtube
videos on the internet aren't really a
proper reflection of the majority of
people that live in this country who
still can't afford food like this so
i'm checking my privilege and we should
all make sure we check ours but let's
play devil's advocate mcdonald's india
has definitely included a lot more
affordable options on their menu and so
they are more approachable to the
average urban indian than other fast
food chains
[Music]
let's compare some items to see who has
the least healthy mcdonald's food in the
u.s a mcchicken contains
400 calories 21 grams of fat 39 grams of
carbs five of those are sugar and 560
milligrams of sodium how about the
indian mech chicken one of these
contains 398 calories 15 grams of total
fat 48 grams of carbs 5 grams of which
are sugars
787 milligrams of sodium so the indian
version has slightly fewer calories way
lesser fats but much more carbs and
sodium
what if we made that a combo meal well a
medium fry in the u.s contains the
following
320 calories 15 grams of total fat 43
grams of carbs no sugar and 260
milligrams of sodium while a medium
price in india contains 340 calories 17
grams of total fat 41 grams of carbs 0
grams of sugars and 256 milligrams of
sodium and if we add the medium coke
that is adding 210 calories no fat 56
grams of carbs 56 of those are sugar and
55 milligrams of sodium oh a nice salty
coke we'll do the same here in india one
medium coke will cost you 151 calories
zero grams of fat 38 grams of carbs 38
grams of which are sugars
and there are zero grams of sodium but
my god that is a lot of sugar packed in
this cup that leaves the indian meal at
a grand total of 889 calories 32 grams
of fat 127 grams of carbs out of which
43 grams of sugars and
1043 milligrams of sodium
which means this whole bad boy all
together is 930 calories 36 grams of
total fat 138 grams of carbs 61 of those
grams are sugar
875 milligrams of sodium a little bit
lower sodium than india but we got you
guys beat in calorie fats carbs and
sugar
we
unfortunately for india the combo stats
are little misleading and the difference
maker is the coke because the american
meal has a larger portion if you order
the coke zero in both countries the
indian meal will actually have a higher
calorie count
mcdonald's india does not share a full
list of their ingredients but there are
some things we do know about their food
like did you know that mcdonald's india
actually changed indian farming
practices just so they could grow the
kind of potato that they wanted when
they first launched in india in 1996
mcdonald's promised the government that
they would use products grown and
sourced right here in india but people
who had eaten mcdonald's abroad realized
that the fries didn't taste quite the
same the reason for this is that indian
potatoes were too small round had way
too much moisture and sugar content and
so the fries made out of them were not
long enough they didn't get crispy
enough and they didn't have that
distinctive mcdonald's
so mcdonald's partnered with mccain
foods and they spent nine years trying
to perfect their potato they imported
saplings which had the perfect shape and
starch content that they needed they
also chose gujarat as their farming
location for its climate and they switch
from a flood irrigation to a sprinkler
system to reduce moisture content and
save water the result
bigger and more starchy potatoes that
can be used to make the mcdonald's fries
that you know and love mcdonald's in the
u.s mostly uses russet burbank or
shepadi shepparty potatoes potato me
so these are big enough they have a
distinctive long fry yeah look how long
this is wow known to be low moisture and
low sugar content this means they can
remain crispy when fried and don't
caramelize too fast so you can get a
nice even browning mcdonald's in the u.s
actually discloses all of its
ingredients so we can figure out a few
other differences in the us for instance
our mayonnaise contains egg yolk as does
most american male thanks to the faq
page on the mcdonald's india website we
found out that the mayonnaise is eggless
along with all of the other sauces
except for the tartar sauce when people
describe things as vegetarian here in
india they typically mean it doesn't
contain egg
from calorie count to portion sizes we
want to find out all the differences
between dominoes in india and the us
this is food wars
here in india our domino's pizzas come
in three sizes our domino's pizza comes
in four sizes the small eight inches
with four slices the small 10 inch which
is 6 slices
the medium 10 inches with 6 slices the
medium 12 inches which is 8 slices and
the large 12 inches with 8 slices
the large 14 inch which is i don't know
four eight nine ten
16 slices because i don't know why they
cut it this way i didn't ask them to so
and the extra large 16 inches or six
slices
unfortunately our large margarita pizza
only comes in one crust option which is
the hand tossed you don't get it in pan
or in cheese burst or any other kind so
i am going to weigh one slice of large
margarita hand tossed pizza to see how
much it weighs
93 grams and i will weigh a slice of our
hand tossed and our pan to compare the
weight please note that our mediums are
the same size as their larges
that's pretty insane
yeah i'm not surprised by that at all
buddy hand tossed
one
random slice is 79 grams a slice
a pan
same
surface size we'll say but obviously a
lot thicker like weight i mean come on
139 grams so that's a little less than
double
this is a large domino's margherita
pizza it's also known as the plain or
cheese in the u.s this is 12 inches long
it costs 419 rupees or 5.55 us dollars
at current conversion rates so the total
surface area of this pizza is
729.7 centimeters square which means it
costs 0.76 cents per square centimeter
of this pizza take our large 14 inch
pizza which is 13.99 or 1056 indian
rupee with an area of 993.1
squared centimeters just like these
slices are squared i totally did that on
purpose that's 1.4 cents per square
centimeter that means the indian pizza
is 45
cheaper than the american version
this is everything you'll get on a menu
at domino's india that you will not get
in america
a little skyscrapers you guys have
actual skyscrapers we have domino's
pizza box skyscrapers here's everything
at the us dominos you can't get in india
we have five it's done we have five
different crust options we have pan
then you have
wheat thin crust cheese burst
is there supposed to be cheese in here
oh
there is cheese in here for sure
then we have hand tossed and we have
something called
new hand tossed maybe somebody else's
hands were used to make this one in the
us our domino's is five crust options
this one right here gluten free but you
can only get that as a small pizza next
over here hand tossed over here the much
thicker pan that's medium only this guy
in the middle here is the crunchy thin
which i just found out five seconds ago
they also cut in squares didn't know
that last and certainly not least this
is the brooklyn style they're thin
slices but you only get this in the
large and the extra large hell yeah that
looks so good just by looking at them i
can tell that the hand tossed
is slightly thinner
new hand tossed
it's a little firmer as a crust i would
opt for the regular hand tossed pizza
finally just for fun the cheese burst
that is such a guilty pleasure so i
thought this was cheese burst in the
sense that just the outer ring of crust
had cheese the entire pizza base
is cheese burst all right here is our
range of vegetarian pizzas here in india
to keep the religious sentiments of both
hindus and muslims who are a majority in
our country we avoid using beef and pork
in most fast food restaurants but what
that means is that we get a lot of
delicious you know vegetarian options
number one mexican green wave i will say
the colors on this pizza definitely look
like the mexican flag jalapenos some
tomatoes onion cheese next up we have
veggie paradise wow
imagine calling an entire pizza a
paradise red peppers capsicum olives
corn and cheese
you guys in the comments let me know
does this look like paradise to you i'm
not in the comments but i'll tell you
right now it absolutely does not it's
funny
their veggie paradise is my pizza hell
next up deluxe veggie mushrooms paneer
corn capsicum and onion
[Music]
i typically don't like when there's too
much on my pizza but the things here
really complement each other pretty good
but again there's so much going on in
this it's truly a deluxe pizza next up
we have peppy paneer how fun red peppers
capsicum
and paneer if you are wondering what
paneer is it's basically cottage cheese
and we love
our paneer okay next up we have paneer
makhani if you're wondering what makhani
means it's a paneer version of butter
chicken if you're wondering what butter
chicken is friend you need a culinary
education
hmm
would i ever want paneer makhani on a
pizza maybe not i don't like it next up
we have cheese and corn it's got cheese
got corn
and finally indi
paneer tandoori pizza tandoor is
basically an oven we use here it's
cylindrical we use wood fire and coal in
it to sort of give the meat and bread
some chaat to it and indi well this
pizza has just not hit mainstream yet
oh that is
spicy and a half if you can't take heat
avoid this one my favorite so far
none of them i will order non-veg pizza
wow india has a lot more vegetarian
options than we do and good for them i
personally don't want any of that we do
have two of our own exclusive veggie
options this here is the pacific veggie
and over here we have the spinach and
feta i don't want to try either of these
do i have to
it's a wasting valuable stomach space
you know like it's only so big all this
awesome domino's food here you think i
want any of this in my stomach who cares
all right fine
what's it got like feta cheese on it
this isn't so bad
non vegetarian pizzas number one we have
the pepper barbecue it doesn't look like
it has any vegetables just a bunch of
chicken pieces and
with a nice smoky barbecue flavor but
you can choose a pepper barbecue chicken
with onion
that is a great combination chicken
sausage quite quite sausagey for sure
the next pizza is what i believe to be
the best pizza you can order from
domino's india the chicken golden
delight what a delightful name this is
one of the oldest pizzas that's been
there on the domino's india menu it's
got nice sweet corn it's got some
jalapenos in there and some delicious
delightful chicken
next we have
the dominator which seems to have every
single neat topping option on the menu
my god
consider me dominated i don't think i
don't think he knows what that means
wow we're learning a lot about nikhil
today aren't we
whatever you're into my man and next we
have chicken fiesta it's got some
tandoori chicken pieces some capsicum
onion
nice simple flavors you can't go wrong
with this one and finally indie chicken
tikka which is just the chicken version
of that paneer pizza i had and that one
just burnt my lips so steer clear of
this one if you can't handle spice but
if you do
this is the one you should get
actually some of those look pretty good
i'm very impressed now here in the u.s
every pizza that has beef on it is an
exclusive and we also got some chicken
ones let's do this i am starving all the
way over here this is the
extravaganza
which looks to have a bunch of veggies
mushrooms and pepperoni
thank you
yeah
this is the meatzza two capital z's i'm
seeing pepperoni ham sausage possibly
hamburger all the meats hell yeah let's
go
[Music]
um i can maybe do one bite of that we're
next turn to sweat next we got the
hawaiian pizza
mmm
a plus on this one
definitely very good cali chicken bacon
ranch you see it looks like it has a
sun-dried tomatoes bacon i'm assuming
and chicken white sauce little flimsy
guy this is the brooklyn style so i
don't know why it's california
oh yeah
no white soft buffalo chicken pizza i
mean they drizzled it on there right you
see that's just drizzled
this one's like surprisingly very good
the ultimate pepperoni not just any
pepperoni pizza the ultimate pepperoni
oh yeah well it's covered in pepperoni
who is right
oh yeah put me in a pepperoni coma oh
yeah oh the deluxe deluxe is just that a
little bit everything black olives
sausage peppers ham probably bacon
you put black olives on anything it just
tastes like black olives ooh memphis
barbecue i am pro barbecue sauce on
pizza it looks like a chicken here too
yeah onions
mmm
yeah
oh man that barbecue sauce that's really
nice wisconsin
six cheese there's no way there's six
cheeses here i don't think i can name
six cheeses we have mozzarella cheddar
asiago is americans that kind of cheese
did i say cheddar yet
blue i don't know
next up if all of those non-veg pizzas
aren't enough for you they have an
entire section called chicken lovers and
they have these four pizzas that look
absolutely insane they're more topping
than pizza at this point this one is
called the chicken five feast so they
have chicken pepperoni chicken tikka
chicken meatballs
there is so much going on over there i
like it but it feels like a drug a pizza
drug
next up we have the spicy double chicken
it has two different types of chicken
pepper chicken and tandoori chicken and
i assume it will be spicy and i'm gonna
take domino's word for it and then we
have chicken
maximus which sounds like a roman
emperor who is also a coward
they have chicken sausage chicken tikka
just a lot of chicken just a lot of
chicken that's that's what this has like
oh my god can i just weigh this it feels
like a small baby i'm holding a small
baby
545 grams for a medium pizza and finally
we have what appears to be
the king of all of these chicken lover
pizzas it's an indo
fusion
max
it sounds like i don't know some sort of
detergent but uh dude you can't even
tell what like what number of
ingredients is on this
i can't even see the pizza at this point
oh my god i feel like a new man you have
to order this once in your life it gives
me deep displeasure to announce that
domino's india has decided to create
these monstrosities called
pizza burgers
is a burger supposed to make this noise
in bangalore where i'm from if
something bad happens to you your friend
will say you got a bun
and this is the bun they're talking
about they have three flavors classic
veg premium veg and classic non-veg
oh
man
no
it's just veggies and so is that cheese
no
no no no no
you know what i thought this would be
bad
and
it's worse
it's much worse it's not a burger like
nothing about this is a burger except
for the bun this might be the worst
thing i've eaten on food was so far
okay
we did kind of the same thing only we
call them sandwiches i've never gotten
one of these outside of food wars i'm
just gonna pick this one right here it
looks like it is a chicken habanero you
wanna everyone wanna get bummed out no
philly cheesesteak listen up
philadelphia domino's wants to make you
guys proud
philadelphia why are you not rioting
right now in the domino's headquarters
wherever it is because this is just
insulting oh no remember the
mediterranean veggie
here it is in sandwich form i also want
this banana peppers on it oh here we go
chicken
bacon
ranch love that combination oh no you
look at this
look at this
this is just too much
this one i just labeled sandwich i
didn't know which one was what the [ __ ]
look at this what is this
is this a buffalo chicken no on this one
guys buffalo
let us know in the chat how insulted you
are by this both residents of buffalo
and buffalo the animals
uh italian
they didn't skip by the pepperoni gotta
give him credit for that one the chicken
parm sandwich
surprisingly bland
they're not terrible but i mean why get
this instead of pizza
continuing the list of exclusive
abominations we have a string of pastas
but also pasta pizzas which look um
fascinating here in domino's india we
use fusilli pasta fusilli being the
whole helix dna strand of pastas we have
creamy tomato wedge non-veg and we have
moroccan spice wedge and non-veg and to
accompany these
i'm sure delicious pastas we have pasta
pizzas in the same flavors wow just
really inventive stuff going on over
here this is the moroccan spice
vegetarian pasta pizza
here we go they ask you how you are you
just have to say that you're fine when
you're not really fine
[Music]
it sent a shiver down my spine it's so
bad
how many different types of carbs are in
this my disappointment is immeasurable
and my day is ruined okay i'm gonna try
one pasta just in case it's good let's
mix it up this one has some tomato sauce
in it
[Music]
this is bad we here in the u.s have our
pasta options that come in penny noodles
these type of noodle guys is that a good
shot of a penny noodle you can get it in
pasta primavera chicken carbonara
chicken alfredo italian sausage marinara
again i don't know why you're getting
pasta to the pizza place
i like which is fine
is this the best pasta you can get in
your neighborhood most certainly not now
on to chicken wings we have three
flavors tomato chili sauce
peri-peri and boneless berry perry i'm
gonna try the peri-peri wings just to
see
how they stack up
they're all right this is your standard
run-of-the-mill chicken wings in a
country filled with millions of flavors
i can't believe we're still doing these
same standard flavors like peri peri
barbecue and ranch where is my chicken
65 my chicken moliga pudi my chicken
ghee roast oh chicken girls dominoes if
you do chicken ghiro's wings i think
you're gonna get a lot more people wings
in the u.s we got them too here's three
flavors that we have here in the u.s
honey barbecue sweet mango habanero and
garlic parmesan domino's if you're
watching you need to effective
immediately stop
doing this i don't know who in your
organization said you know what we
should do instead of tossing it in the
sauce you know how everyone expects the
wings to come we'll just put on here and
drizzle look at this look at this mess
toss it toss the wings toss in the sauce
toss it in the sauce that's how everyone
does this house supposed to be done
next up exclusive sides number one
cheese pops
tater tots as you call them we have
fries and they're crinkle cut that's
unique not a lot of restaurants here in
india do this they have been flavored
with a bunch of stuff though so i think
they've used their
oregano and chili flakes over here they
have here a veg parcel it's like a
little puff with the same you know
paneer pieces over here
then they have
what they call uh tacos there's a
vegetarian version with some
simple veg
cutlets and they have a non-vegetarian
version with
a slab of chicken i do not expect that i
am speechless at the level of quality
these sides have compared to the pizzas
then you have a chicken parcel and
finally they have
little meatballs of chicken with
peri-peri dust on top of them this is
literally just one of their
pizza toppings that they're selling as a
side yes
india has breadsticks and stuffy cheesy
bread but they don't have garlic ones
but we got those we also have these
parmesan
twists
look at these twisty guys and for
stuffed cheesy bread you can get it as
spinach and feta or bacon and jalapeno
dips this i don't know what they just
were like how can we give people pizza
without bread behold
this
it is
a dish
of cheese and marinara sauce they're
calling them dips cheesy marinara
and the five cheese come on look at that
look at that oil you see that right
there
exclusive sauces at the us dominoes you
know what that means
sauce talk
here you can get these exclusive sauces
in the us can't get them in india we got
hot buffalo
sweet mango habanero
honey barbecue
ranch
ooh blue cheese
for the wings right and
garlic
yeah it says ranch they gave us two
ranches instead of a ranch and a garlic
and marinara they're like generous in
the marinara that's a big one
we have two separate dips over here in
domino's india we have a cheesy dip and
we have a cheesy jalapeno dip
cheesy dip
ooh
oh that tastes good okay cheesy jalapeno
dip really yum
something about this tastes spoiled is
this fast it's expiry date it tastes
like curdled milk go with the cheesy
jalapeno dip for sure it's time for
desserts
dessert
we we just have one dessert here in
domino's india but it's a banger this is
a choco lava cake you heat it up
and boom
gooey
lava goodness
oh wow
this fixed everything that was wrong
with the menu of dominoes up until now
just eating this is so comforting i can
feel those memories
of the pasta and the burger and that
ridiculousness that they served slowly
disappearing from my head like like
thoughts from dumbledore's head when
he's near the pensieve
hey india check out these desserts we
got you can't have them uh over here we
have a marbled cookie brownie and go for
brownie right
[Music]
what the hell dude these are great oh my
god
it's cookie dough and brownie what a
great idea
miss tips i don't know who i don't know
who in your organization
said let's do dips but you need to let
that person go it's like chunky
applesauce
and cinnamon twists
now it's time for drinks yet again it's
pepsico winning over here we have pepsi
we have 7up and
mirinda
unlike a lot of other restaurants
domino's is yet to switch from plastic
bed bottles to something like cans or
reusable
cups
drinks you get in the u.s can't get in
india almost at the uk jesus i'm
cracking up
coke
diet coke
orange
the doctor
sprite
dasani water i'm taking the dr pepper
it's time for calories our large hand
toss margarita pizza has
256.4 calories per slice so that means
the full pizza is
2051.5 calories which is over twice your
daily recommended protein intake and
172.5 percent your daily sodium intake
our large cheese pizza is 2
240 calories that's a
9.19 increase from india's cheese pizza
look i screwed up
i needed a thin crust for the crust
section
of this video and i just randomly made
it this large
just
understand that
maybe
victoria can you do me a favor and take
this pizza here and just like put it
right there like you just do that in
post please
next up one slice of a large deluxe veg
pizza is
220.5 calories and so the entire pizza
is 1760
calories
this is our large pacific veggie veggie
pizza and it is 310 calories per slice
which makes the full pizza 2
480 calories that's a 40
calorie increase in the us and
get a load of that sodium over 200
percent your daily amount at domino's
india our highest calorific pizza is the
chicken dominatrix
chicken dominator the chicken dominator
dominating the calories i guess one
slice will cost you 399 calories and the
entire pizza is a whopping
3192 calories which is
159.6 of your recommended daily intake
please
steer clear from eating an entire
chicken dominator
our u.s dominance pizza with the most
calories is this the cali chicken bacon
ranch one xl brooklyn slice of this it's
560 calories that makes the full pie
3360 calories that's 168 percent your
daily recommended calorie amount it's
worth it it's delicious go get a slice
tell them joe from food worth sent to
you
they'll have no idea what you're talking
about
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between subway and india in the u.s this
is food wars
subway sandwiches in india come in two
sizes six inches
12 inches
subway in the us also has those two
sizes six inch
and 12 inch now the website also says
there's a four inch sub called a chota
sub chota small but mysteriously it is
unavailable we called four outlets
wasn't there and now we shall measure
the 12 inch sub to see if it actually is
12 inches
keeping them honest right that's 12
inches
all right subway i'm getting more than
12 inches here subway has given me a
13-inch sub
this is why i love subway fun doesn't
stop there because in the us subway also
offers catering options first you can
get this a platter which is five foot
long subs cut into threes making a total
of 15 pieces
the discrepancies continue here in india
the website says that we too have a
platter option but we called a bunch of
stores no platter option
and on top of that in the us you get a
three foot long party shop
we didn't get it this time
graphics can go ahead and put a three
foot party cell right in front of me
thanks guys
okay is my ex-girlfriend running the
subway india website because it's full
of lies they not only advertise a three
foot sub but a six foot giant sub and
surprise surprise we called a couple of
stores no six foot giant sub in fact
they said there are barely any six foot
humans here in india why would there be
a six foot sub and i was like yeah sorry
i am the idiot hang up
okay i am a short thing
175 centimeters
this is how much i
measure
now this is a six foot sub next to me
why would this be a thing
it's taller than me
well
joe is six feet tall so
go ahead and
uh
so if graphics go ahead and make me a
sandwich in three two one
you know this is pretty comfortable can
we do the rest of the shoot like this
ah this is pretty nice here in india
subways actually opted out of using a
lot of plastic which is why they only
stock these 330 ml cans
which i am going to measure just to make
sure we are not being fooled by pepsico
smells like my teeth decaying
yeah looks about right 330 ml
subway in the u.s we're still totally
using plastic cups small
medium large and the large is supposed
to be 40 ounces why someone would want
to drink 40 ounces of something that's
not malt liquor in one sitting is beyond
me but if you want 40 ounces of soda
good lord subway has you covered i of
course i'm curious to see if there
actually is 40 ounces in this drink full
food wars transparency i did have to
fill up my own fountain drink let's be
honest could we agree that if you had to
get your own drink fill it up to go you
would probably get this much now keep in
mind the cap is recessed
everyone roasts me in the comments i'm
not filling up enough like you can only
fill this thing up so much
oh my god not even chloe you know i'm
even gonna like get the condensation on
the cup in there just to even like help
tip the scales in their favor right 34
6 you guys are
just say it's the 34 ounce cup now 35
ounces we're still gonna get it
still gonna get it shame on you i saw
that john oliver episode terrible subway
shame on you where you do the
franchisees and what you're doing
skimping on the sodas
here are all the subway menu items from
india that you won't find in the u.s
here's all the subway menu items from
the us you won't find in india obviously
subway lets you customize your
sandwiches so we're not talking about
every single different combination we're
just going on what is on the menu now
let's begin it's glorious this feels
like a subway buffet
and i get to pick whatever i want first
of all the aloo patty this is basically
potato which has been cut up into pieces
and then fried with bread crumbs on top
mmm this is not bad but i think you can
add all the fancy sauces you want into
this thing nothing will beat a humble
mumbai vada pav corn and peas that looks
like a lot of mayo i don't think i shall
ever order this sub this is a local
legend the harabara kebab sub this is
the first thing a vegetarian will order
at an indian restaurant because it's
this delicious mishmash of spices
vegetables and potato fried
tangy delicious next up we have a
mexican patty i would like to extend
an apology to all my mexican brethren
watching that their great culture has
been reduced to a patty of aloo and
beans
paneer tikka beautiful pieces of cottage
cheese as you call it
is it weird for me to bite a subway
right through the middle
would that upset you
[Music]
it's nice i wouldn't go with this
particular combination of vegetables and
sauces also i just want to point out
there are literally three pieces of
paneer in here when i used to go to
subway in college i would make sure that
they put in like a lot of protein
this is despicable
veg chic kebab she kebab typically is
minced meat that's sort of pressed onto
your skewer and then grilled but this is
a veg version it has a lot of different
mixed vegetables and potato
hmm
that's pretty yummy i love the onions
the sauce combination is great and the
sheet kebab itself lot of flavor next up
we have the vegetarian shami kebab uh as
you can see they're nice round little
balls xiaomi kebabs are from lucknow
here in india they have a very crispy
exterior and a delicious melt in your
mouth interior they typically mince meat
but this is a vegetarian version let me
try this
oh
best one so far i'm so full
next up chakpata chana subway what a fun
name chatpata means full of masala zingy
flavor
really delicious chana is lentils it
looks
kinda like a dirty diaper but i assure
you this is gonna be absolutely
delicious
oh yeah
that's pretty good now on to the
non-vegetarian subs starting with this
one the indian chicken tikka looks
pretty good
i just took a mouthful and there was
absolutely no chicken every bite should
have a bit of everything chicken kofta
kofta is basically
meatballs and this is chicken flavored
you can see the meatballs right there
wow that's actually really good whoever
picked the sauces on this one this is
the way
barbecue sweet onion bit of ranch a bit
of mint mayo
this is the best sub out of all of them
i actually think it's the combination of
sauces that makes the sub what it is
it's leaking flavor peri peri chicken
ever since mcdonald's released peripery
fries here in india there has been a
peri-peri revolution over here but
a peripheral evolution
as i like to call it lot of chicken lot
of meat um not a lot of veggies what
happened here some olives would have
been nice and finally this rejected
subway over here is
tandoori tofu which i refuse to eat on
principle because we also have paneer
over here it looks pretty much the same
and i'm sure it tastes great you know
what i realized subways opened up like
this don't really look all that great on
camera do they
oh my god this looks like somebody's
organs
us exclusive sandwiches you know they
say greatness is in the agency of others
well i'm here to say greatness is in the
agency of other
sandwiches i've tried almost
none of these starting over down here we
have something called the mazza meat
let's take a look at this julie oh i
don't think i've ever seen this before
look they even got like the little like
uh
like the fresh mozzarella
is what looks to be all the italian
meats oh by the way unless otherwise
important to the sandwich i got
everything with lettuce tomato and onion
and like no sauce unless it includes a
sauce so
some mercy on the people had to wake up
two hours earlier to make these
sandwiches it's just like yeah just put
the same junk on all of them moving on
supreme meats
oh yeah
this is up my alley salami the other
salami
ham no turkey though huh this is kappa
gold what is this provolone cheese
this is something that i would probably
get at subway the baja turkey avocado
you know what enough for you here turkey
oh yeah hey they were generous with the
avocado i think right going right in the
middle
no big deal
moving on
honey mustard rotisserie style chicken
oh yeah
i like the flavor that better than like
the regular chicken the all-american
club ham turkey bacon
the baja chicken and bacon
it's like weak
even the bacon doesn't have a lot of
flavor
let's get into the steak baja steak and
jack cheese black forest ham
buffalo chicken
oh yeah look at that well they were
generous with the buffalo sauce chicken
bacon ranch
what does it say like the strongest
flavor and this is the tomatoes you guys
don't have the cold cut combo
that looks like bologna
then we have this next one
the meatball right
india
i assure you this tastes way better than
it looks
roast beef is you guessed it roast oh
god i turned the bread pink is that
normal oh spicy italian a favorite of
mine
two salamis both spicy you know just
like in italy
the turkey cali fresh i i think when
something's a cali sandwich the cali
means bacon and avocado the steak cali
fresh
which has let me guess bacon and uh
avocado no now there's the bacon
[Music]
so unless i got covered in the past five
minutes the food at subway has seemingly
become incredibly bland steak and cheese
these steak sandwiches are like bricks
i'm look at this oh yulie yeesh
now there are some sandwiches which
appear on both menus but have little
differences when it comes to ingredients
for instance our subway club comes with
turkey ham and bacon and our italian bmt
has ham
in india our subway club actually has
turkey lamb and chicken slices and our
bmt does not contain bacon this is
because most fast food outlets here
don't serve ham or beef because it will
hurt the religious sentiments of hindus
and muslims in addition to our sandwich
fillings we also have some differences
in our bread options we have honey oat
multigrain we have roasted garlic and
parmesan oregano italian white bread but
this looks oddly similar to the american
italian cheese and herbs
is it the same thing joe let me know no
here's exclusive u.s bread options at
subway cheddar jalapeno bread
gluten-free bread tomato basil wrap and
herobrine in both the u.s and india you
can get any sandwich as a wrap or in a
salad bowl other us exclusive option is
the melt i wasn't gonna get every single
melt uh the list goes as follows baja
chicken and bacon melt chicken and bacon
ranch melt baja steak and jack melt
buffalo chicken melt ham and cheese melt
italian bmt melt meatball marinara melt
oven roasted turkey melts spiced italian
melts steak and cheese melt and tuna
melt i went ahead and got two steak
melts and
which one oh brother the tuna melts
oh god it looks like cat food
oh
and i definitely don't have coven cause
i tasted that i need a steak and cheese
melt uh pellet cleanser after that
now we're talking here are our breakfast
sandwich options we have egg and cheese
chicken slice egg and cheese and western
egg and cheese
i am very curious to know what makes
this western
i can see how this would be a western
option nice bland
easy on the palette
let me tell you something about india
all right if you flavor something that
we're buying at a restaurant with just
salt and pepper we call that a ripoff at
least
at least 10 spices
for some
in conceivable reason you can get their
breakfast sandwiches
full on flatbreads oh god this and
they're so greasy
egg and cheese oh look how terrible this
looks
oh no
where's the cheese and what oh come on
man
[Music]
absolutely not
this really is a bummer
oh my god
did you hear that like i mean these eggs
are you kidding me with this what
[Music]
i couldn't imagine
eating a whole one of these for
breakfast
without going directly back to bed
the black forest ham egg and cheese
[Music]
oh god and now let's never speak of
those breakfasts ever again we have some
exclusive subway toppings here in the
u.s you cannot get in india such as
spinach banana peppers
and monterey cheddar cheese according to
the subways website in certain parts of
the country you can also get avocado
carrot guacamole sweet peppers feta
cheese pepper jack cheese provolone
cheese
swiss cheese
here in india unfortunately all the
toppings we have are also available in
the us damn it subway are we not special
enough guys let's up we know in the
comments what special toppings we should
have here in india however we do have
our own exclusive sauces
sauce talk starting with mint mayo which
is absolutely a banger and the entire
world needs to taste this tandoori mayo
which we end up using because we overuse
the mint mayo this balances it out
and finally
red chili sauce i've also never heard of
mint mayonnaise and that sounds
incredible actually so in the u.s we
have a few of our own exclusive sauces
such as ranch oil subway vinaigrette and
plain mustard you guys have honey
mustard like us but not plain mustard
and in certain locations around the
country you can also get buffalo sauce
creamy italian sauce golden italian
sauce savory caesar sriracha and oh
tzatziki cucumber tzatziki or this is
the tea silent ziki zed seeking cucumber
in my defense i am incredibly nauseous
what if we took
all of the us exclusive items and put
them in one sandwich well this time
we're not going to and thank you we
actually made an effort to make an
edible
us only sandwich what we have is a steak
sub cheddar jalapeno bread with spinach
banana peppers monterey jack cheese
ranch and mustard
this all works well together except the
mustard stands out which is kind of a
could do without it and the spinach is
fine don't taste the spinach so i guess
wouldn't kill me to get some green in
here now what about an india only sub
here is one with roast garlic bread
tandoori chicken tikka mint mayo
tandoori mayo and red chili sauce
i'm really feeling the lack of exclusive
toppings your subway this is just meat
dripping and sauce
make india exclusive toppings happen
right now subway this is the eat pray
love version of a sub in the sense that
it makes sense to everybody else in the
world except indians moving away from
subs our snack section will tell you
that we have a pepperoni toasty and a
veggie toastie unfortunately at the time
that we ordered it was not available i
have tasted them before though and the
pepperoni one is pretty yummy subway has
potato chips of course and these are
some us exclusives starting on this end
sun chips cheddar harvest sun ships and
subway have always had a really good
alliance good for them
my favorite
miss vicki's the jalapeno chips these
things are so good you can also get the
miss vicky's lime and cracked pepper
chips the one i went to
didn't have them this i can't believe
you guys don't have the nacho cheese
doritos i mean this is like
like the most popular chip right and
last
lays
baked and also kids can get a pouch of
applesauce i'm assuming adults can get
it too but they're technically for kids
in india subways chip options are a lot
more limited and they vary from store to
store the one we visited had a variety
of flavors in coronitos which are
basically nacho chips and layers and
they had my personal favorite lace
flavor west indies hot in chile but the
crew has informed me that they will not
roll further if i don't give a shout out
to india's magic masala
our subway cookies have one exclusive
flavor and that is this the raspberry
cheesecake
this is so good
i don't know how they do it we sought to
have an exclusive here in india in the
u.s you can get a chocolate chip cookie
but here you can get
dark chocolate chunk cookie or if you
really want to join the dark side a
double dark chocolate cookie
here at the subway in the u.s coca-cola
rules everything around me we got a lot
of coke products here i put these in
order of which one i would probably want
to have with a sandwich coke diet coke
not a big diet guy but it's like egg
with the calories next is sprite i mean
who doesn't love sprite it's a little
strong i don't think it goes well with a
sandwich but why not then we move on to
the simply drinks you got yourself
simply lemonade it doesn't like lemonade
right simply orange juice i feel like
this is more for the breakfast
sandwiches right i mean oj after
11 11am seems kind of strange to me and
then this apple juice if you want to
have an energy drink with your
sandwich vitamin water xxx
and then gator gatorade
yeah i mean i like gatorade but i mean
it doesn't pair with food at all
last but not least
all-natural energy green tea hydrated
coconut water antioxidants electrolytes
with
ribose
let's find out
whoa that's terrible this one smells
like b.o
here in india subways actually partnered
with pepsico so instead of coca-cola
products you can get things like pepsi
mountain dew pepsi black mirinda
tropicana orange juice and aquas water
from the makers of aquafina that's so
complicated why
it's like a movie title at this point
which country is getting a better deal
on its subs let's compare a foot long
turkey sub in both in the u.s this will
cost you 8.99
in india ordering a foot long turkey
club sandwich on zomato one of our food
delivery apps will cost you
476.19 rupees that's around 6.27 dollars
right now and while that's 30 cheaper
than the us sub it's still pretty
expensive for the average indian for
context in under seven dollars you can
feed an entire family of four and you're
gonna get a very delicious hearty meal
in most restaurants over here now to
play devil's advocate the subway near my
college back in the day
had a crazy deal going on where they
gave us a six-inch sub a cookie and a
drink of our choice in under two dollars
and we used to eat lunch there nearly
every single day so i guess
from store to store there are different
offers and subway is and can be kind of
affordable subway prices have been a
contentious issue in america for a long
time a franchisee named stuart frankel
invented the 5 foot log back in 2003
which hit the mainstream in 2008.
cheaper labor and food costs combined
with an increase in foot traffic meant
the promotion was actually a huge earner
for subway sadly it didn't last and the
deal was phased out around 2012. when
subway tried to bring it back in 2017 it
was met with uproar from many
franchisees who said it was impossible
to make a profit from the promotion the
same thing happened again in 2020 when
subway tried to push a ten dollar for
two foot logs deal which was killed
after two weeks
which country subway is the most
unhealthy let's start with a foot long
turkey sub add whole grain bread with
lettuce tomato onion peppers and
cucumbers in the u.s this sandwich
contains 520 calories 6 grams of total
fat 2 grams of saturated fat 78 grams of
carbs of which 12 are sugars and 1580
milligrams of sodium in india the
nutritional information for this same
sandwich is 586 calories 6 grams of
total fat 4 grams of saturated fat 94
grams of carbs of which 8 grams of
sugars and 1 362 milligrams of sodium
when you break food down like this it
sounds pretty scary
so the u.s sandwich has more sugar and
more sodium than the indian version they
have the same total fat content
i don't know what need to take from that
but the indian version has more calories
saturated fats and carbohydrates than
the us version my theory is because we
have that extra inch
what's the most calorific thing on the
us menu currently it's a foot long cali
fresh steak sub with smashed avocado on
whole italian bread one of these is a
hefty 1220 calories there's also
68 grams of fat in there 87
of your daily allowance as well as 2 380
milligrams of sodium over 100
of your daily allowance the most
calorific thing on the indian subway
menu is this
paneer tikka sub foot long whole wheat
bread with standard salad it's a
whopping 820 calories
now this is less calorific than the
american cali steak sub and contains
significantly less fat at just 41 of
your recommended daily intake the main
thing to watch out for however is the
saturated fat there's 16 grams of it in
here which is 80 of your recommended
daily intake oh saturated fats you sly
dog from calorie count to portion sizes
we wanted to find out all the
differences between burger king in india
and the us this is food wars
[Music]
in burger king india our drinks come in
one standard size which looks to be your
small or medium but you can also opt for
a can of 330 ml burger king in the u.s
our drinks come in four sizes value
small
medium
and large
let's measure this cup to see how much
is actually in here doesn't make anybody
else want to pee
or is it just me
34 ounces well it's just 38 at the
bottom of the cup it ain't 38. our
burger king fries come in two sizes
medium and king
our fries come in four sizes value small
medium large
i remember the large being bigger than
this i'm just glad that the fuss we rose
for the first uk us
food wars burger king has
resulted fry transparency next up
chicken fries i didn't know this was a
thing so i'm very excited to eat them it
should have five pieces three
four
five
six
thank you burger king
oh never mind one of the fries had
broken they gave me five ours also is
one size nine chicken fries it's like a
pack of chicken cigarettes
seven eight nine a nice brown on brown
yeah we thought ahead for this one the
next one we shoot them i'm wearing all
brown on a brown jumpsuit
we're gonna paint this brown the most
unwatchable series
here's everything you'll find on the
menu at burger king india that you won't
find in the u.s and here's everything
you can get at a u.s burger king you
can't get in india let's begin with the
whoppers this is a good time to mention
that here in india most fast food
restaurants do not serve beef or pork to
keep the religious sentiments of both
hindus and muslims conservative hindus
will not enter a restaurant that serves
beef conservative muslims might not
enter a restaurant that serves pork all
right keeping all of that in mind let us
begin with the chicken whopper oh
boy okay burger king definitely has
larger burgers than most of the
restaurants here in india look at this
it's the size of my face i am the burger
king
that's so good you might notice if you
are a regular burger king consumer of
the foreign lands that if you were to
eat this one it's a little spicier and i
think they've done that because most
indians love their spice there's a lot
of bite to it next up double chicken
patty whoa whoa whoa whoa this one's got
some heft to it huh the mutton hopper
mutton if you are unaware is goat meat
and burger king is one of the few fast
food chains here that actually serves
red meat of some kind indians love their
mutton i love my mutton
it's definitely more meaty has a lot
more bite to it than the chicken god
birding what are you doing the quality
is out of control
every beef burger at burger king is a us
exclusive got all the whoppers let's
start down here the little guy the
whopper a junior not enough meat you say
get yourself a double whopper same
burger two patties can they go bigger
they can the
triple whopper look at this thing
hey
close your mouth when you're taking a
picture the texans of the audience might
have to help us out in the comments here
the texas double whopper texas prides
itself from what i can tell i know he's
going bigger so why wouldn't it be the
texas triple whopper a rare moment where
texas was reserved
texans of the internet i think you guys
need to step in here i don't think that
sandwich is doing you guys proud on to
the wedge options this is a veg whopper
i expect great things from this bad boy
i would say this is pretty lackluster
next up veggie double burger
if you want double the disappointment
another thing that we have that
technically isn't beef is the impossible
whopper which is made with impossible
beef i'm actually very curious how does
the impossible burger patty taste joe
regular beef
i have the ham too it tastes exactly the
same i want to give the environment a
break maybe get one of these every once
in a while next up we have an exclusive
king collection of burgers these better
be uh quite royal and aristocratic
number one hot and cheesy veg
a lot of jalapenos
the patty actually has like cheese melt
in it hot and cheesy king's collection
on a scale of common villager to the
king himself
i would rate this
village bard once in a while you want
him there just to appease a few people
but otherwise
pretty lackluster paneer royal
just by the name itself
this one
should be incredible so paneer if you
don't know is cottage cheese and here in
india it is almost a staple we eat it
and everything we eat in curries we
sometimes just sear it and eat it plain
and obviously it had to make its way to
burgers
the paneer is really good chewy and
delicious i would rate the paneer royal
a local baron helps the king around a
little bit now on to the two non-veg
options we have fiery chicken food plain
and simple they just want this meat to
blow my mind
it's just spicy that's all it is it
doesn't have the depth of flavor that
the chicken whoppers did chicken
tandoori if you guys don't know what a
tandoor is it's basically this
cylindrical oven that we heat up using
wood fire and charcoal traditionally and
we use it to create everything from
kebabs to breads i doubt all burger king
outlets have an actual tandoor in their
restaurants but let's see if they were
able to replicate that smoky flavor
on a scale of absolute street urchins to
maharajas i would rate these two court
traitors
that tried to backstab the king and now
they're on trial they have a lot of bark
but not enough bite they're going to be
executed soon non-whopper burgers aka
burgers get yourself something called
the big king that's what it looks like
don't have it what we do have is the
single quarter pound king bacon king
i always say generous amount of bacon
that's great then these little much more
reasonable sized burgers bacon
cheeseburger bacon double cheeseburger a
bacon free double cheeseburger right one
of the most hilarious things on the
burger king menu is of course a rodeo
burger a burger with barbecue sauce and
onion rings cause why not
yeah cheeseburger regular dry ass
hamburger who cares enough kingly
sandwiches it's now time for the regular
vegetarian options that they have we
have crispy wedge crispy wedge double
crispy wedge with cheese
bk classic bk classic with cheese light
whopper junior and light whopper junior
with cheese
why is it called light whopper junior
how many more things do you need to add
to the name to make it seem small mini
light small whopper junior
kindergartener burger how about that
next time burger king okay i don't want
to try any more veg burgers but this one
the bk classic veg seems different like
the bun
looks to be the same but they've
definitely used more perky buns here
don't use that audio clip out of context
okay finally if you're a vegetarian i
would recommend the bk classic with
cheese
boom although it is currently for a
limited time thought i would share with
you guys here in the u.s we have the
south west options at burger king
starting with the southwest bacon junior
the southwest whopper the southwest
impossible whopper what makes it
southwest oh i'm seeing like crispy
little chippy guys oh spicy oh it's got
some heat to it yeah there's guacamole
on here hang on
what kind of [ __ ] with it i wouldn't eat
it if i didn't work at food wars you
know
and now for the chicken sandwiches these
look so tiny compared to the whoppers we
have crispy chicken crispy chicken
double crispy chicken with cheese pk
classic chicken spicy grilled chicken
big smoky grilled chicken light hopper
chicken junior light whopper double
chicken junior and light copper
chicken junior cheese
yes i could work at burger king right
now we're going to try this two of these
burgers just to see if they're any
different first one the spicy grilled
chicken
oh my god i can imagine myself going to
a drive-through taking one of these
driving to work sitting in silk traffic
getting annoyed with all the other
people honking realizing i should have
gotten a bigger burger and next day
ordering two nice next up the big smoky
grilled chicken
i don't see how this is smoky at all in
fact it's kind of sweet and to the naan
beef options i personally think these
new chicken sandwiches are fantastic the
chick king that's ch apostrophe king
because it's burger king spicy chicken
sandwich same thing got some spicy sauce
on it this is very good if you like
these but want a little more veggies
because you're some old fogey here you
go vegetables they also make the chick
king deluxe deluxe equals lettuce and
tomato this car crash of a sandwich is
the spicy actually the spicy with
veggies is actually kind of nice the
coolness of the the lettuce and the
tomato actually counter balances the
spice the original chicken sandwich
shaped like the new iphone for some
strange reason this guy's been around
forever it's their answer to the
mcchicken it tastes exactly like a
mcchicken chicken junior there's a
little guy
a spicy chicken junior and last the only
naan chicken thing in the chicken
section is the big fish
and now for a set of snacks that comes
under their stunner menu
[Music]
we have king egg burger king egg wrap
crispy veg wrap veg crunchy volcano
that's right this is not even a wrap
this is a little geological formation
tikki twist burger veg makhani burger
and chicken makhani burger and finally
crispy chicken wrap and crunch chicken
volcano all right the first burger we're
trying is the chicken makhani burger so
makhan means butter and it also means a
lot to us indians you just walk in the
room and you say makhan it will resound
through the room like people's eyes will
perk up the hairs on their arms will
rise
oh my god yeah
okay so they've gone for like a butter
chicken makhani flavor but it just
tastes like tomato puree over a stale
chicken patty next thing that i really
want to try is the the volcano itself
and i think this is their answer to taco
bell's crunchwrap
oh that's pretty good he was this close
to offending two communities and mother
earth herself but pretty good next thing
i'm going to try is an aloo tikki twist
tiki twist sounds like a cocktail but
aloo tikki is actually it's like mashed
potato fried with bread crumbs and it's
used in charts it's used in a lot of
other dishes and they put these crispy
shards of what seems to be
the same material
in the volcano
illuminati confirmed
[Music]
and to breakfast is
we got breakfast at the bk in the u.s
you can get an assortment of chris
sandwiches biscuits melts i didn't get
all of them starting down here a crew
sandwich of course for those who not in
america is they took a crescent
and stuff eggs and cheese and your
choice of breakfast meat bacon egg and
cheese croissant sausage egg and cheese
croissant ham egg and cheese croissants
bacon egg and cheese biscuit sausage egg
and cheese biscuit ham egg and cheese
biscuit cheesy ham breakfast melts
sausage and cheese breakfast melt cheesy
bacon breakfast and for both the chris
sandwiches and the biscuits you can also
get pretty much every combination of
meat egg and cheese onset biscuit or
sandwich egg norma's burrito ah no no no
no no i am not starting off my morning
with this no thank you this looks like a
dirty diaper like what is any of this i
feel like if i bit this in like one bite
of this in the morning and i'm on the
toilet get yourself two platters sausage
and pancakes platter and this one i
think it's like the platter deluxe you
can sell pancakes get stuffed bacon get
yourself eggs and of course syrup next
up chicken wings burger king here sells
boneless chicken wings they feel like
chicken tenders on me
the super meaty it's like proper chicken
it's not like that processed nuggety
chicken juice thing that happens in the
u.s our burger king has nuggets and they
come in four pieces
and eight pieces
i asked the burger king employees about
the 16 piece and they said they don't
have a 16 piece they just give you two
eight pieces now it's time for burger
india's sides and sauces number one we
have the classic periphery fries they
give it to you with a little sachet of
the peri peri powder and a little shake
bag pour it in there
voila your simple plain fries are now
periperied
hmm
go with mcdonald's peri-peri fries i'm
sorry burger king too powdery almost
chalky and the flavor is not quite there
okay
periphery prices come back for the
vengeance fair enough there is a bit of
spice to it next up cheesy fries
italian cheesy fries and i don't know
what makes these italian but
i think it's a whole lot of oregano and
finally veggie strips well the bk here
in the us and get yourself onion rings
jalapeno cheddar bites see what this
looks like mozzarella stick matz
applesauce
can't have nuggets without sauces you
know what that means
sauce talk as for the dips we have easy
cheesy twisted mustard
fiery hell
they literally named one of their dips
fiery hell
first up buffalo sauce honey mustard
ranch sweet and sour zesty sauce do we
know what this is
that is just mayonnaise and like brown
mustard marinara sauce
salsa del sol
it is milkshake time burger king has
three flavors right now they have
mango
berry blast and chocolate
guys at the time of filming this it is
currently mango season here in india
none of you have tasted a real mango
until you've tasted the king of all
mangoes alfonso available here
everywhere you go right now you're going
to get a delicious mango milkshake we
also make something called amras which
is like a delicious mango
juice that wheat with puris and stuff
let's see if this compares to fresh
mango juice
oh
it's pretty good it's not too sweet it
just kind of tastes like mango ice cream
sort of mixed but i like it i really
like it next up berry blast paper straws
burger king thank you the dolphins
appreciate it just as much as i do
whoa i did not expect that flavor here
we have something called black currant
ice cream that's rampant in uh very
demented families that order the the
black current ice cream i'm sorry to
single out these indian families like
this but this tastes like that i'm
sensing a pattern here so it won't be a
surprise to me if the chocolate
milkshake also just tastes like watered
down chocolate ice cream
the mango one i suppose if it wasn't
mango season you could go and get a
mango milkshake but otherwise go to any
other fruit or milkshake store in india
get a nice thick mango shake with actual
mangoes
way better on to the cold drinks let's
start with the shakes over here we have
a frozen coke you can also get a frozen
fanta wild cherry sounds amazing our
burger king did not have it first one is
this the oreo shake
why is that so good it's like a shake
made out of the stuff in the middle
brilliant idea and you can also get
chocolate oreo shake
no it's not this one's better this one's
very good desserts i'm a sucker for
desserts but why would you order dessert
from a fast food place unless i'm going
to be proven wrong first up they have
chocolate mousse cup okay it's got a
little bit of cake at the bottom
chocolate chocolate chocolate at the top
chocolate chips on the top
too decadent very sweet next up they
have a choco lava cup keeping in theme
with their random volcano based food
items and i'm sure this would ooze out
chocolate but you have to heat it first
that is so sweet when would i eat this
i'm trying to think of when i would eat
something this sweet
never we have three dessert exclusives
the first one is just the hershey's
sunday pie chocolate chip cookies a
soft-serve cup or cone where is it joe
well it's roughly 100 degrees here in
southern california and that thing would
have melted into a soup before even got
it to the studio imagine either a sauce
sort of ice cream cone or a melted soft
serve ice cream cone would be more
accurate as for cold drinks we have
pepsi mountain dew mirinda which is an
orange soda and iced tea all of these
are under the pepsico range of products
and of course in india the pepsi slogan
is
swag which means every sip has a lot of
swag
and i have to live with this cringe for
the rest of my life now
here in the u.s we have obviously a
variety of exclusive drinks can't get in
india
coke
dr pepper
diet coke there it is barks baby fanta
orange i should say that at least the
bks that i go to here in sunny southern
california has those coke freestyle
machines so you can also get yourself an
orange juice it's really funny looking
at orange juice next to orange drink
like look at the difference with it
orange juice orange drink capri sun
apple juice burger king iced coffee the
bk cafe which is of course probably milk
let's talk price a single indian chicken
whopper will cost you 199 rupees or 1.56
us dollars at current conversion rates
in the us a whopper costs
8.79 or 668
indian rupee that's around a 236 percent
increase in price make it a meal with
medium fries and a large drink and it'll
cost you 383 rupees or 5.03 us dollars
add a medium fry and a medium drink to
the order and that brings a price to
16.37
or
1246 indian rupee again about a 225
increase now upgrade to the large size
and it's 407 rupees or 5.35 us dollars
make it a large 16.77
or
1276 indian rupee it's a 214 percent
increase 200 rupees for a single burger
is actually very expensive and while
fast food in the u.s and other foreign
countries might seem like something that
the average person can easily afford
here in india this is expensive and only
the upper middle class and the rich can
actually go out and have a burger like
this in fact in mumbai where we're
filming this right now our most popular
street food is vada pa which is like a
potato burger and it cost costs 15
rupees which is 20 cents it can fill you
up
downgrade the cost upgrade the taste get
a vada pop to better illustrate the
price difference let's compare the u.s
large whopper combo to our combination
of two whoppers two crispy chicken
sandwiches five piece chicken strips
king fries and four drinks
all of this still costs less at just
1102 rupees or 14.45
dollars we would have to add a crispy
wedge with cheese and a crispy chicken
with cheese to get around the same price
but again i have to remind you that in
14 an average family here in india could
eat at home for a week
calories time my favorite part of these
videos because i realize
how much i should not be eating this
food let's start off with the crispy
chicken sandwich from burger king
it has 430 calories and in the u.s our
crispy chicken sandwich is 670 calories
next up is one of burger king india's
most popular burgers the wedge whopper
at
728 calories
imagine that high calories low taste
we don't have that but in the us our
burger king does have the impossible
whopper which contains 630 calories next
let's compare the fries an average box
of king sized fries will cost you 535
calories
if i had to choose between these fries
and an hour of cycling
let's be real i'd probably skip the
cycling but
this is still bad it's a lot of calories
and in the us a large fry has 430
calories and now for some reason if
you're really looking to pack on those
calories introducing burger king india's
most calorific sandwich the masala
wedge hopper
at a total of
730
calories
yeah yeah the website of burger king
india also says they sell a 15 piece
grilled chicken wings with a total of
1256 calories but we called a bunch of
stores it was unavailable and i think
they discontinued it because they did
not want to kill half the country oh yo
yeah this is definitely
a block of calories and the usb k our
most calorific sandwich is this
the bacon king just one of these bad
boys 1
359 calories
oof
god damn it brown on brown on brown
brown brown on brown brown brown brown
brown brown
hey you gotta handle these fast food
companies man they make this [ __ ] look
real appetizing for what is literally
how many different shades of brown